welcome to the world of business
analytics where data holds the key to
unlocking success in the corporate realm
in this comprehensive video course will
take you on a transformative Journey
empowering you with the Knowledge and
Skills to harness the immense power of
business analytics tools whether you are
a business professional seeking to make
data-driven decisions or an aspiring
analyst eager to dive into the world of
data this course is your gateway to
becoming a master of business analytics
tools together in this business process
analyst full course will learn the
following first we will learn what is
business Process Management followed by
that we will go through what is business
analytics next we'll Master the
fundamentals of business Process
Management then we will understand who
is a business analyst next we will dive
into the steps describing how to
becoming a business analyst in 2023 up
next we have the affect business analyst
roadmap for 2023 next we will discuss
the top 5 business analyst
certifications followed by that we have
W in-depth tutorial along with the
Netflix data analysis project using
Tableau also we will be covering the
power pair tutorials for big mess 2023
followed by the introductions and some
use cases we'll be covering the data
modeling in power bi next we will go
through business analytics with Excel we
will also cover the Excel macros and VBA
for beginners up next we will deal with
SQL Advanced tutorial for business
analytics next we have a brief
introduction to business analytics with
r we'll also deal with some critical use
cases of business analytics with r and
finally some important and most
frequently Asked business analyst
interview questions and answers let's
embark on this transformative adventure
together that's it if you are an
aspiring business analyst looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in collab
session with leading experts then search
no more simply learns postgraduate
program in business analysis from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be a right
choice for more details choose the link
mentioned in the description box below
also if you are already a business
analyst and want to upgrade your skills
to become a successful data scientist
with proper training and certifications
from experts and reputed universities in
Caltech data science bootcamp should be
the right choice for you for more
details choose the link mentioned in the
description box below and if these are
the types of videos you would like to
watch then hit the like And subscribe
button and the bell icon to get notified
also before we get started let's hear
from our Learners about the personal
experience and their success story after
getting graduated from the business
analytics postgraduate program offered
by simply learn I have always been
passionate about learning new themes and
improving my teaching skills about five
years ago I realized that I have a gap
in my knowledge and to fill the Gap I
needed to kill myself I chose increment
at my upskilling partner because of all
it's comprehensive curriculum and its
connection with Urdu University how hi
my name is Carlos vinares I live in
Lexington in the city of Kentucky in the
United States
I am an assistant professor at Midway
University and I hold a PhD in
management human resources and
Leadership I decided to opt for the post
graduation program in business analysis
from simpler which has helped me a lot
to my professional and personal life
I have been teaching even before I moved
to the United States years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
tools it was very difficult for me at
the beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly review I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis and
starting in fall 2012.
I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose simply learner and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
if you see how the business work is
changing now and it's killing yourself
is quite essential to keep up with the
change everything works on numbers now
data is more valuable and important than
ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing and with that in mind
over to our training experts
first of all let's understand what
business Process Management is
business process management or BPM as an
organizational discipline in which a
firm examines all of the operation
processes collectively and individually
through this assessment companies aim to
identify areas of improvement to create
a more efficient and effective business
environment in simple terms business
Process Management is all about
optimizing and improving companies
business processes that serve customers
and eventually bring the pile of Revenue
BPM is vast discipline that by
definition is dynamic given the
continually changing organization roles
regulations method corporate goals and
other Factor it contains BPM has evolved
with time to accept a wide range of
optimization approaches from Six Sigma
and lean management to a child we'll
discover these approaches in depth on
some other day first let's dive deep
into the details of BPM if we break down
nuts and bolts of business Process
Management we'll find out three key
factors the first one is of course
business processes the second one will
be the set of inputs and the third one
will be the output retrieved after
processing presented inputs for example
consider the bank loan application
process here the customer will supply an
electronic application form via the
bank's website to receive the desired
loan plan let's say a home loan in this
case initially the input provided by the
customer will go into the loan
application process now the loan process
is not one small process there are
multiple operations and regulations
involved in it such as credit checkups
quality control loan management
underwriting
Etc all these tasks are cumulatively
considered as business processes as
mentioned earlier all these processes
will start once the customer provides
some sort of input in this case it is an
electronic application which will be
forwarded to the salesperson by Banks
ITT by evaluating the submitted
electronic application A salesperson
will formulate the list of loan products
in order to present them to the customer
but if a customer is interested in some
specific banking product for instance
Home Loan in such a case the sales
person will provide customer details
about home loan a home loan has certain
eligibility criteria which customer will
have to fulfill so salesperson will ask
for setup documents such as ID proof
income Source or salary slip property
documents Etc the initial phase of loan
application is also known as
pre-qualification process
in the next phase the administrative
team will evaluate all the documents
submitted by the customer and forward
them to the credit analyst system at
this point the credit department
receives the application and the first
step is to analyze it for accuracy
genuineness and completeness
if all the needed fields are not filled
out the application will be returned to
the borrower or credit analyst who will
contact the borrower to get the missing
information
the credit team uses the loan
origination system to determine a
borrower's credit worthiness a good loss
will help A lender Bank set up workflows
to process a loan it may automatically
flag files that have missing needed
fills return them to the borrower and
tell the sales department that they need
to be reworked to manage this Tech a new
Department of information and Technology
will also come into play this particular
step of application evaluation is also
known as underwriting process in the
next phase the credit decisions are made
if customer fulfills all required
criteria the application will be
approved or if the customer lacks
somewhere the application will be
rejected in the next phase quality
assurance will be achieved because
lending is highly regulated business
Banks rely heavily on the quality check
stage of loan origination process the
application is routed to the quality
assurance team which Compares crucial
variables to internal and external
standards and regulations this is the
finest type of loan procedure before it
is submitted for funding now consider
all these processes altogether each
process works on feedback of other
process or some new input hence managing
every input and process can increase the
speed of business operation by removing
internal miscommunications service
delays customer complaints Etc and PPM
is the field of management that exactly
Works towards achieving that in short to
Define it in more simple terms I would
say BPM is all about managing multiple
input streams and intercommunication of
business processes to generate desired
business outcome within the least amount
of time possible
this BPM comprises of three main pillars
people processes and Technology all
three aspects are required to work hand
in hand for a BPM project to be
successful the business process needs to
be fit for purpose and actually satisfy
the demand for all the stakeholders
having said that let's discover the life
cycle of business Process Management
technology and management both are
crucial factors for BPM so the life
cycle commences the collaboration of
both with five standard steps the first
one is design then we have model
implement
Monitor and finally optimize
a large team of I.T and management
experts is required to construct the BPM
project
the management team will study related
set of business processes in great
detail and then try to redesign it with
the objective of optimizing it so that
it becomes more purpose oriented all of
this happens during the design phase of
the project here all the processes are
carefully designed to be as
straightforward as possible by making
use of standardization and it automation
that is why the space can be completed
in a shorter period of time next we have
as a modeling phase
during this phase the process gets
documented in the form of an activity
model it allows experts to simulate the
system's behavior and try out different
scenarios through a what-if approach
once the process is approved by higher
management by looking at the modeling
and simulation sheet it is then executed
and deployed over the information system
this phase of business Process
Management is known as implementation
phase here if management finds out some
discrepancy the corrections can be made
by employing standard methods and
automation
the fourth page of BPM is monitoring
in this phase the performance of
business process is monitored to see if
anything goes wrong
if any problem occurs during the
monitoring phase it will be further
optimized in the next phase of business
Process Management this phase is known
as optimization often this phase remains
continuously under the Run since the
good BPM always improves its business
processes on an ongoing basis moving
ahead let's talk about the benefits of
business Process Management
the first benefit is increased
visibility of business processes a good
BPM implementation will increase the
visibility of banks activities making it
easy to Monitor and control the critical
business processes of the bank
vpm also provides management increased
ability to identify bottlenecks in
simple words a process bottleneck is a
work stage that gets more work request
than it can process at its maximum
throughput capacity an example of a
short-term bottleneck would be a skilled
employee taking a few days off if this
occurs planned operations will not be
done on time leading to the drift in
business performance the other type of
bottleneck would be a long term
bottleneck it occurs all the time and
can significantly slow down production
an example of long term bottleneck is
when a machine is not efficient enough
and as a result has a long Cube BPM can
help companies make improvements and
reassign resources to meet customer
demands by identifying this bottlenecks
the next benefit of BPM is reduce lead
time by controlling all business
processes altogether and monitoring each
process in a silo BPM increases the
accuracy and speed of business
operations for example the loan
application process that could have
taken months can now be finished within
weeks because of Control process
handling by BPM this increase efficiency
allows Banks to convert leads into
potential customers with no time so
definitely this is the hottest benefit
that BPM has to offer the next benefit
is a clear definition of employee roles
a good BPM ensures planning Optimum
roles and duties for the teams as well
as employees since people resources is
also the important factor BPM aims to
manage the BPM system prevents
unfortunate situations where a customer
who phoned to inquire about a loan
application is transferred from one
individual to the next and next with all
of them saying sorry it's not my
decision to make but let me transfer you
to the person who deals with it BPM
enables a cross-functional approach to
avoid this scenario so the work is
automatically moved from one disk to the
another without any need for manual
intervention the sixth benefit is
Unified systems and operations since in
BPM no process remains in a silo by
itself all processes come closer to each
other making business a complete unified
system
the last benefit on our list is expanded
growth potential as discussed earlier a
successful BPM increases customer
happiness and Lead conversion which
directly increases a company's revenue
and market value
it is no surprise that business
analytics and business intelligence are
two of the fastest growing markets in
the world organizations today are
generating data at a rapid rate there is
a need to use this business data and
make smarter decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact-based decision
making on the other hand business
intelligence or bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively
consider this example
suppose you sell homemade chocolates
through an online store business
intelligence provides meaningful
insights into the past and current state
of your business bi tells you that sales
of your milk chocolate have spiked up in
Texas the past two weeks so you decide
to manufacture more milk chocolates to
keep up with demand business analytics
asks why did sales of milk chocolate
Spike up in Texas by scrutinizing your
website data you learned that most
traffic has come from a post by a food
blogger based in Texas who like to make
chocolate
this Insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States
using Cutting Edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as Microsoft
Excel SQL power bi and Tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth business analyst
is a professional who is responsible for
Bridging the Gap between I.T and
business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense so you should have a clear
understanding of the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-function requirements in a business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills the skills for a business
analyst are not only acquired through
training but through experience and
combined with the ability to understand
situations and the motive behind the
problem so let's have a look at the top
skills to become a successful business
analyst the first skill we have is
understanding the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improved revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increase in marketing budget according
to the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill a business
analyst would have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says five percent of
the people think 10 percent of the
people think they think and the other 85
percent would rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession if
you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point the use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders non-verbal
communication skills enable the
effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills business analysts
also perform cost benefit analysis to
conduct an assessment of the benefits
and costs anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have a knack to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deep player titier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualize Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analysts to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth scale in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems while business analysts are
generally not responsible for making
decisions regarding project Solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding Gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assist decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution now let me ask you
guys one interesting question what is
the primary goal of conducting a SWOT
analysis option A identify market trends
and customer preferences
option b accessing the financial
viability of a business venture option C
evaluating the internal and external
factors impacting a business option D
developing strategies for product
development and Innovations please
answer in the comment section below and
we will update the answer in the pin
comment you can also pause the video
give it a thought and answer in the
comment section now let's dive back into
our video business analysis is like
being a detective for a company it helps
a company figure out what it needs and
how to make things better business
analysis is done for all sort of things
a company wants to do whether big or
small it can be a part of specific
project or ongoing as the company grows
and improves think of it this way
business analysis helps a company
understand where it is right now where
it wants to go and how it gets there
it's like looking at a map and planning
the best route for a journey it's
important because it helps the company
make smart decision and find ways to
create value for the people involved
so if you are into solving Mysteries and
helping companies grow business analysts
might be the perfect role for you
so till now you must have gotten an idea
of what business analysis is now we will
see who is a business analyst
a business analyst is a person who
performs business analysis tasks
described in a bab okay which is the
business analysis body of knowledge
no matter the job title or
organizational role business analysts
are responsible for discovering and
analyzing information from a variety of
source within expertise including tools
processes documentations and
stakeholders
now let's see what business analysts do
the activities that business analysts
perform includes business analyst
understanding Enterprise problems and
goals analyzing needs and solutions
formulate strategies Drive changes and
facilitates stakeholders collaboration
moving ahead with the positions that we
have in the business and let's discuss
with the education and skills needed for
the career path let's begin with
discussing the typical salary range of
an entry-level business analyst position
it's important to keep in mind that the
salary figure depends on various factors
such as location industry and Company
size however we can provide a general
idea of what you might expect
for entry-level business analyst in
India the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is typically between 3
lakh to 6 lakh per annum and in the US
the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is approximately
between 50 000 US dollar to seventy
thousand US dollar per annum
now let's see education and Foundation
first you will need to get a bachelor
degree in business and administration
computer science or relatable feed it's
like building a strong Foundation of
your career to boost your credentials
you can also consider getting
certifications after that sharpen your
skills acquire domain knowledge and
develop your analytical skills by
learning tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software these are like
secret weapons that will help you
analyze data and find important insights
you should also learn problem solving
methods and how the model processes it's
like becoming a problem solving
superhero now hands-on experience to
really level up look for internships
entry-level positions or projects within
your organization this will give you a
practical experience and allows you to
contribute to the requirements Gathering
documentation and testing it's like
going on a real life mission and making
a tangible impact by following these
steps you will be well on your way to
become a skilled business analyst you
will be the hero who has businesses make
smart decision and drive success
now let's talk about senior business
analyst salary for senior level business
analysis in India the salary range can
be between 6 lakh per annum to 12 lakh
per annum
in the U.S the salary range of a senior
business analyst is typically between 70
000 US dollar to 100 000 US dollar per
annum for education and Foundation
consider pursuing a master degree in
Business Administration or a relatable
field to depend your knowledge and
expertise explore Advanced certification
such as certified business analyst
professional or project management
professional acquired domain knowledge
continue expanding your understanding of
the industry and its Trend challenges
and emerging Technologies develop a deep
understanding of specific business
domain with the industry
next analytical skill development
enhance your data analysis capabilities
by exploring Advanced Technologies
predictive modeling and data
visualization
familiarize yourself with business
intelligence tools and advanced
analytics platforms hands-on experience
take the lead on large projects and
handle critical business analysis
activities
mentor and support Junior analysts
provide them with guidance and
assistance remember the key is to
continue learning gaining practical
experience and staying up to date with
the industry trains good luck with your
business analysis Journey after that we
have lead business analyst the salary
range of a lead business analyst in
India can vary from 12 lakh per annum to
25 lakh per annum and in the US the
salary range for lead business analyst
is typically between 100 000 US dollar
to 150 000 US dollar next education and
Foundation take Advanced certification
and specialized training in leadership
and business strategy you should also
acquire domain knowledge become an
expert in your industry by staying up to
date on Trends regularizing on new
technologies
next analytical skills development is
very important develop expertise in
advanced analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence learn about
tools and Technologies for predictive
analysis and data-driven decision making
next we have business analysis
Technologies Master the art of
facilitating and negotiating in complex
stakeholders engagement
last hands-on experience take the lead
on strategic initiatives and large-scale
projects play a significant role in
shaping your organization's business
analysis processes and methodologies
everyone processes at their own pace
based on their skills opportunities and
Industry demands keep seeking
professional development take on
challenging tasks and build strong
relationship with the industry to
accelerate your growth as a business
analyst
it's a business analyst
a business analyst is a person who works
with companies to study their systems
services and products in order to
enhance present operation and come to
profitable judgments
a business analyst
evaluates the business model and how to
integrate it with technology to assist
organization in documented business
processes a business analyst is
responsible for processing and analyzing
the products and services to make
profitable decision to improve the
financial activities of the organization
business analysts handle all the
requirements demanded by the clients and
convey them to the product development
team now it's time to learn skills
required to become business analyst
analytical skills and critical thinking
great Achievers are great thinkers
the role of the business analyst comes
at the beginning of the software
development lifecycle a business analyst
must analyze the client requirements
effectively critical thinking helps the
analyst in examining different
situations and providing a solution
communication skill every role demands
communication skill but communication is
the key for every business analyst they
are supposed to have talked with
stakeholders a good business analyst
needs to have communication in different
phases be it with clients product
development team or the implementation
team for instance if a product needs to
be implemented then it is the duty of a
business analyst to communicate with the
clients regarding requirement clearly
otherwise the entire project May
collapse as a business analyst
facilitating meeting is very important
first point to boost your confidence if
you have good communication skill
database and SQL
SQL is an important skill that every
business analyst needs to understand a
database is a software to store the data
business analysts should have hands-on
experience on SQL from which they can
fetch data from these databases so it's
better to know MySQL Oracle DB no SQL or
mongodb
programming skills it's good to know
programming languages like python or r
business analysts have to deal with lots
of data that are beyond the limits using
spreadsheets so if you know Python
programming language it helps in
analyzing the data as well as we can
easily integrate it with SQL databases
to automate tasks
R also works in the same way R helps to
create interactive graphs and help in
analyzing the data
reports and dashboards business
dashboards are increasingly seen to help
business analysts to produce data in an
insightful way
dashboards are Consolidated with charts
and graphs on a single screen the
purpose of dashboard is to help business
analysts by allowing them to gather and
analyze the data let's say we have 10
sets of people working on a project we
have to maintain a dashboard in such a
way that it is understandable and
accessible to everyone so that everyone
can understand the growth of the project
these were some of the important skills
business analysts need to have
how to become a business analyst if you
are a fresher this is a very important
part
firstly it's essential to decide and
concentrate on the fundamentals of the
business analytics understanding the
fundamentals and choosing the right path
are crucial in every field start
learning the fundamentals of business
analytics first and start mastering it
pursue the related course it's a
reminder to you to have a look at the
business analyst master program link
which is given in the description box
below you can take up a business
management course and get certified to
become industry ready
internship an internship is a fantastic
way to learn more about a field or job
you might like to pursue internship in
business analytics will help you deal
with real-time experience working in
Industry this will automatically improve
your resume start taking up real-time
projects on Business Development and
Analytics lastly apply for a job
build a portfolio including your
practical experience the portfolio
should consider all the internships and
projects you will be qualified to apply
for a job after you get all the
experience necessary this used by a
business analyst we have covered some of
the important tools frequently used by
business analyst based on its use
project management tool jira the
collaboration tools jira and Confluence
are very practical to collaborate
effectively on projects and share
requirements every business analyst has
to be at least familiar with jira by
using platforms like jira all business
stakeholders May engage with various
teams and view the status of their
project
Trello is a project management platform
businesses use for teamwork and task
organization dividing the work into
columns on a board enables you to manage
your projects and effort dividing
complicated projects into smaller more
manageable and reliable chunks of Labor
help simplify and standardize your work
so for this purpose Trello is very
important tool
data visualization
the main use of data visualization tools
is the ability to quickly solve business
related problems Tableau is the prime
software for data visualization it
creates efficient visualization which
makes the stakeholders understand the
data more effectively
power bi is a software created by
Microsoft that meets your analytical and
business needs
a visit allows access to data even when
using third-party programs and services
for instance you can integrate it with
SQL Server you can enable python with
power bi tool that offers customizable
visualization by including data
normalization and purification the
functionality of a desktop program can
be greatly increased using power bi as
we have already learned reports and
documentation is the key skill for a
business analyst to create report and
documentation we use Google Docs Google
Docs provide you with templates for
business research business analyst may
share and collaborate on documents
effectively using Google Docs with the
use of Google docs business analyst can
communicate with stakeholders about any
kind of file or document
Microsoft PowerPoint as we previously
discussed good presentation skill is
always counted for a business analyst a
business analyst must have ability to
present project teachings to their
stakeholders so it's necessary to learn
Microsoft PowerPoint these were the
important tools for a business analyst
to manage their work now comes roles and
responsibility played by a business
analyst in Industry a business analyst
has a variety of roles and
responsibility therefore it is crucial
to understand thoroughly the roles and
responsibility held by business analyst
before learning how to become one
a business analyst pinpoints the goals
and issues of a company's business and
develops profitable Solutions
the assembled stakeholders and business
requirements they help in analyzing and
evaluating business processes an
organization has and identify the area
of improvement
business analysts collaborate with the
development team to create a plan for
addressing a specific issue they
aggressively offer feedback on the
design of a software program and
integrate the newly created features
that a company needs
business analysts evaluate companies
functional and non-functional
requirement different roles performed by
a business analyst are data analyst
business architect system architect and
product manager these are the roles
which are interdependent on a business
analyst in an organization so the top
companies hiring a business analyst
they are Accenture IBM Deloitte TCS
VMware McKinsey and Company we can also
include meta in this list this is the
job description provided by Accenture
for a business analyst role key
responsibility will include working with
clients and Technical Resources to
identify their business problem and
developing the analytical solution good
knowledge and understanding of digital
application
planning and managing business diagnosis
and planning activities understanding
and analyze functional impacts on front
to back application design and document
new process and system changes
performing interpreting requirement
analysis to identify value creation
opportunities for clients on average
Accenture offers 76
000 dollars per year for a business
analyst Rule now we will see job
description in IBM so what will be your
responsibility being a business analyst
in IBM be part of international teams in
the design build test run faces of
customer projects from various
Industries and interesting business
domains this role as its clients and
projects in implementation of wide range
of application and business processes
communication with business owners and
end user to Define business requirement
and with development team to ensure
delivery to the agreed standard and
quality support testing in the
resolution of Defense learn and apply
processes and methodologies related
latest IIT Trends from both the JD we
can understand that business analysts
have to deal with clients a lot
so on an average eighty four thousand
dollars per year is the salary offered
for a business analyst working in IBM
and the final part is salary of a
business analyst
the average salary of a business analyst
for refresher is seventy thousand
dollars per annum in USA and experienced
is one hundred thousand dollars per year
an experience level you should be able
to evaluate and measure business
Frameworks and how they influence an
organization and their clients
coming to India the average salary of a
business analyst
for fresher ranges from 8 lakh per year
for experienced it can go as high as 15
lakhs per year and more also such as the
demand for business analyst all over the
world you are prepared to begin your
career in business analytics because you
have a better understanding of what
business analyst does their roles and
responsibility and steps involved to
become one so the postgraduate program
business analysis by simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to equip
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as business analysts
this program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
enhance their business analytics skills
and Advance their career in the field so
this program covers various topics such
as business analysts Essentials project
management data analysis data modeling
and data visualization
it also includes Hands-On training in
popular business analyst tools such as
you will see here such as Microsoft
Excel jira power bi and many others upon
completing the program Learners will
receive a certification from Simply
learn and the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst they will also have access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
overall the postgraduate program in
business analysis by simply learn is an
excellent option for individuals who
wants to enhance their business analysis
skills and Advance their career
perspective in this field so now next we
have business analytics boot camp by
simply learned this is an intensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business Analytics the program is
delivered online and is intended for
individuals who want to understand
business analysis comprehensively and
how it can be applied to real world
business problems this program covers
various topics such as data analysis
data modeling data visualization and
predictive modeling it also includes
Hands-On training in popular analysis
tools such as R python Excel and W the
business analytics bootcamp is designed
to provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in meaningful way it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insights and
recommendations to stockholder
effectively upon completion of the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
in the business analyst role access to
simple learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
now let's see more about the business
analyst Masters program this Masters
program I simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to
provide Learners with a deep
understanding or business analysis the
program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
advance their career prospectus in the
field of business analysis the program
covers various topics such as business
analysis Essentials project management
data analysis data modeling and data
visualization it also includes Hands-On
training in the popular business
analysis tools such as Microsoft Excel
Microsoft power bi R and python numpy
sci-fi to business analyst master
program is designed to provide Learners
with the skills and knowledge required
to succeed as a business analyst it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to effectively communicate with
stockholder manage projects and analyze
data upon completing the program
Learners will also get the certification
and the skills and knowledge required to
succeed in the business analysis role
which provides guidance and support to
help Learners transition into the job
market
the link will be in the description box
for all the courses next we have simply
learns business analytics for strategic
decision making certification program
which is designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business analysis and how it can be
applied in the real world business
problems the program is delivered online
as intended for individuals who want to
understand business analysts
comprehensively and Advance their career
this program is delivered by Indian
Institute of Technology roorkee this
program covers various topics such as
strategic analysis data modeling data
visualization predictive modeling and it
also includes Hands-On training in
popular analysis tools such as again
Microsoft Excel R and W the business
analysis for static decision making
certification program is designed to
provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in a meaningful way it
also focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insight and
recommendations to stack holder
effectively upon completing of the
program the learner will get the
certification by IIT roorkee and simply
learn we will also have the access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to web
Learners transition into the job market
the link will be in the description box
for this course also now we have simply
learned Sports graduate program in
business analytics in a comprehensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a deep understanding of business
analytics the program is delivered
entirely online and is intended for
individuals who want to advance their
career in the field of business
analytics the program covers the range
of topics such as statical analysis data
modeling data visualization machine
learning and Big Data
so this program is sponsored by Purdue
University and you will get the
certification from IBM this program
covers a range of topics such as
technical analysis data modeling data
visualization machine learning and Big
Data it also includes Hands-On training
in popular analysis tools such as
Microsoft Excel R programming Python and
tableau the postgraduate program in
business analyst is designed to provide
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst or data scientist it focuses on
developing the necessary skills to
effectively communicate insights and
recommendations to stakeholders manage
projects and analyze large volume of
data upon completion of the program
Learners will receive a postgraduate
program in data analysis certification
from Simply learn and the skills and
knowledge required to succeed as a
business analytics or data sensor they
will also have access to Simply learns
Career Services which provides guidance
and support to Learners transition into
the job market that's it if you are an
aspiring business analyst looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learn postgraduate
program in business analysis from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be a right
choice for more details choose the link
mentioned in the description box below
in this session we will start with
certain exercises which we will perform
in Tableau in order to understand some
basic concepts
now in order to learn Tableau the basic
first step is to import a sample data so
in our case what we have done is we have
imported a sample Superstore which is in
Excel format a sample superstore.xl
which has three worksheets in it orders
people and returns so by importing this
data into Tableau first of all we will
create relationships between these
sheets in order to identify who all have
placed orders and how many people have
returned the orders we will do some
analysis on the orders placed by certain
set of people and Order returned by
certain set of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders
table the order sheet on the
relationship canvas here okay and you
can see the data sample data the first
100 rows over here
okay then now we need to create an inner
join with people's table between order
and people okay so if you see
it has automatically detected the field
names on which the inner join has to be
created so on the order side you have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people data
so if I close this box and go and check
the people's data
open
foreign
and the person these two columns from
the people table have now been
joined with the orders table right so it
means that these are the orders in a
particular region which has been placed
by
in this region
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by customers
across multiple regions
south west of USA South Region west
region then you have a list of order IDs
which have been returned so basically
the order ID in the returns sheet
matches with those orders in the orders
table
and then you have the people
sheet in which you have region
and a person associated with that region
the sales person associated with that
region okay so basically when we are
combining joining orders with people we
are joining that
which orders
belongs to which region and who is the
sales person associated with it so what
we have done over here is we have made a
inner join means all the orders should
belong to particular region and that
region is in the people's sheet
and then in the second step
now we will make a
left join between returns and orders
not inner join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the
order ID
okay so just edit this
click on left
and
select order ID as the join column now
what does left join means left join mean
is that consider all the orders from the
orders table and only consider the
orders from the return statement which
have data means which are returned
otherwise show null for the order IDs
which are not returned so if you see
this is the these are the two columns
from the return statement and these are
null because this is relevant to the
order IDs which are not returned okay
which has been accepted by the customer
but these are the orders for which you
see data in the returned and Order ID
column it means that these have been
returned
now with these joins in place please
save your book and now we have our
relations created in the
um
in the Tableau now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model
now we'll move to sheet1
okay
and first we will place
state
and person on the rows
sheet okay
then
I'll go to my
numbers and
put the profit or D so per state per
person how much profit I am making as a
company okay this is my goal to check
now sort by highest to lowest
so California is giving me the maximum
profit of seventy six thousand six three
hundred eighty one then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I have
listed my profit in descending order
now I can also check what are the number
of orders
placed
and check the distinct count
so out of 120 out of the total orders of
127 okay so this is the number of total
number of orders which have been
returned for California is 127.
it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as per
the revenue as per the profit and this
is the details of the orders which have
been returned per state
so if you see for connected for a
cancers there are zero returns
so you can also extract data
table to refresh his orders and identify
new rows using order date so as and when
new data is being added you can
refresh it now say extract
and now you can save this information
profit
by state
and click save so this is the extraction
of this particular report which is
possible in tableau
so this is the first exercise which we
have completed for
reviewing and analyzing the profit per
state highest to lowest and within that
per state what are the number of orders
which have been returned by all the
customers the distinct count of order
IDs which have been returned
now let's start our second exercise on
creating calculated fields in tableau
now in this exercise we will be doing
certain
activities like we will be creating a
set to show the states which have more
than 100 customers then we will be
creating a calculated field to show an
average sales per customer okay then we
will create a calculated field to show
the sales goals and then show emerging
and developing stage so these are the
four kpis which we have to derive
now the first thing we have our sample
Superstore data already imported and the
relationships created in a join with
people and left joined with returns
now we have our sheet 2 in which we will
create the states a list of states which
has more than 100 customers so what we
have to do is we have to click right
click on the customer name and click
create set
okay
now we have to give the name as states
with 100 plus customers
and then go to the condition tab
select by field
and then apply condition as
count of customer name
greater than equal to
and click
ok
now we have this set created states with
100 plus customers
now to determine average sales by
customer
we have to now create a calculated field
so go to the analysis and click on
create calculate field
okay
now name it as
average
sales per customer
and now we will say average
we will use a
foreign
that per customer we are using a level
of definition function include which
means that per customer what is my
average sales right we've already used a
function aggregated function called
average so we are saying per customer
give me the total and then give me the
average per customer so we're going to
click ok
now create another calculated field you
can also create from here and name is as
name it as sales goal
now in this we are going to type the
formula if
minimum
States
with 100 plus customers equal to true
then
sum of
sales
into 1.3
else
average sales per customer into
100 so me we are saying that
if the customer belongs to the set of
states with 100 plus customers then the
sales Target should be
1.3 times the actual sales as of today
else it should be 100 of the average
sales per customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging
or developing state
if distinct count
of customer name
is greater than equal to 100
then
the state is tagged as developing state
foreign
state
okay so we have now three calculated
Fields average sales per customer
emerging or developing State and sales
goals
now we will use this in our reporting
so we will drag sales goal under the
columns
and then I'll drop my state
so now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or not
then add your customer name
make the measure as count distinct
and make it as discrete
okay so if you see this
we have the count of customers per state
and the
the sales goal
for that particular state
and now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want
which is there per state
now go to show me and select
this particular chart
bullet graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales access and select
swap reference line fields
now from your left hand panel drag and
drop emerging or developing State on the
color panel
okay so a merging state is the orange
one and the developing state is the blue
one
and save the sheet as
developing and the emerging States
so if you see this it's an emerging
State because its count is less than the
customer count is less than 100
its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is 19511 okay
so now this is a developing State its
count is greater than equal to 100 and
its sales goal and its sales is exactly
the same it matches so that's why you
are saying the bar and the blue bar is
ending exactly where the vertical bar is
so what we are trying to depict is that
whether the state is going Beyond its
Target sales goal or it's behind it
and you can see that using this
particular vertical bar like for example
Michigan its sales goal is 71 952 but
its actual sales is seven six seven two
seven zero average sales so that's why
it is be above its Target
and it's a developing state
because it has more than 100 customers
so you can even sort
by the count of
the uh customers higher to lower so all
your developing state will group from at
the top and the emerging States Will
Group at the bottom
or you can sort by
the sales goal
so the orange bar is the sales goal or
the blue bar so depending what sales
goal
has been
derived for each state
hello and welcome to this new session on
tableau now in this session we will talk
about how to prepare dashboards and how
to Interlink reports within the
dashboard
so in order to start this session we
will first create couple of reports and
then include them in the dashboard and
then link them together
so for this session
as usual we are using the sample
Superstore data set for our example
now first we will create a report where
we are gonna
show profit by region per region
so first we will drag the region
in the rows column and we will get all
the regions
and
state
so we have all the states per region in
our report now and then we will drag
sales
and profit
so now we have our sales and profit
measures the column level
now just also drag now the region to the
color section so now we have each region
colored
the entire sales and profit per region
is distinguished by the different colors
Central is south and west
now
click on the
colors
now we want to show the labels using the
marks card okay so we want to show the
region
okay so we need to include the show the
marks labels just a second
so enable the labels
say show Mark labels
okay
so you have on the left this is the
profit and this is the total sales now
rename
this sheet as region and state analysis
report
okay
now let's create another worksheet
now in this sheet just drag the state
on the
marks card now automatically Tableau
will detect that you know you have
dropped a particular State and we have
the states of United States so it has
identified the state names and showed
you the identifiers of the states on the
map and automatically
identified the latitude and longitudes
which are generated by Tableau and given
you the markers on each and every state
now drag the sales measure to the color
panel
okay so now this is sales per state in
the color scheme with the color scheming
then now Drag The Profit to the size
so now each state you have the color the
profit and the sales
now you can edit the colors and you can
select
a particular scheme of colors and say
apply and okay so now you are able to
distinguish
the colors on the state
now after this
just rename the sheet as
profit by state
report
now create let's create another report
now in this report drag the subcategory
to the column section
and
sales and profit measures in the
rows
okay
now click on the right click on the sum
profit pill and check dual access
now click right click on the profit
access and say synchronize access
now select some sales from the card
marks card and change the notation as
bar
and for profit change the notation as
line
so now this is a fair display of
sub category wise
sales and profit representation that
these are the sales and what is the
profit
now go to the marks all marks and drag
the category section
the
category section as the tooltip
okay so for each and every bar or line
item you should now see the category
also
save your report
and
rename this now report as sales
by and profit by sub category report
now let's create a new dashboard
now the reports which we have just now
created first our dashboard size let's
make it as automatic
okay then
let's show the dashboard title click
click on the dashboard title
now drag the reports which you have
created
profit by state
sales and sub category report
and region and
okay so you have all your three reports
in a single dashboard now
profit by state sales and profit by sub
category and region by and state
analysis report now we will link these
reports so go to dashboard
click on actions
add an action called new filter
select Source sheet in the source sheet
dashboard 2
only select region and state analysis
report
and in the Target sheet just deselect
region and state analysis
on the source sheet keep the Run action
on select and
click
ok
now whatever state you select over here
that particular state will be used as a
filter across both these reports so it
means in North Dakota you have all these
category subcategories being sold and
their Associated profit and on the map
profit by Straight report you can see
the North Dakota State being highlighted
or only selected and the relevant profit
and sales
okay so here is the total profit in
sales in the profit by state report and
in this sales and profit by sub category
report you have the breakup of the
profit and sales across the categories
similarly you can select any other state
and automatically the
filters will get applied automatically
see this Marine Main
okay
so with this we cover our example of how
to create multiple reports and then
connect them
or encapsulate them in a single
dashboard for a single view across all
these reports
in today's session we are going to take
example of the Netflix database which we
have and we'll prepare certain reports
in order to identify what kind of
reports we can generate from such a data
set
So currently on my screen what you can
see is the Tableau the Netflix data
sheets the data sources where you have
the Netflix shows movies their
Associated duration uh what kind of
shows or movies are there the release
here are the associated rating
description and key which is the show ID
now this is the unique identifier for
each show in this Netflix title sheet
and with this show ID all other sheets
are related like you know who are the
directors of the show in which country
the show was released what is the cost
of each show all that information is in
this sheet and to which particular
category basically the listed in
category is being uh listed in this
particular sheets so what we're going to
do is first we are going to import this
sheet into tableau
okay and then create relationship
between them using the Tableau
relationship canvas so first our the
primary transaction table the sheet in
which all the information related to
movies is there or shows is there is in
Netflix titles and then we will drag
sheet like Netflix cast titles cast now
Tableau has automatically identified the
relationship between the show ID of
titles and show ID of titles cast and it
has made a join
so if you double click this
you can see this relationship
cardinality and the related fields
similarly I'll drag release titles
category
countries and directors
Now by virtue of this all the sheets
have now been joined with Netflix titles
and with this relationship ready we can
start preparing our reports
now let's create a basic report where we
can just glance the data like you know
whatever we were seeing in the Excel how
it looks in tableau so you have all the
types of movies then
for example I drag the release Here
now first I do not want to consider it
as a
Dimension so I'll just
release here or category per type there
is a release Here and then I'll drop the
listed in
so now these are the categories so per
year the details of the categories right
and then you can
drag the title and the associated rating
so this is just a view of your data
we can name it as shows listing report
now let's try to create some report for
some
measures some numbers
Etc
so now let's check in which country how
many movies or titles were released you
know what is the count
so first let's drag the
country
so as soon as we drag the country
uh
field it is identified that it has the
geographical names and identified the
latitude and longitude details so
Tableau internally does that
automatically and it has identified the
spots across the globe of the relevant
country
now let's drag the listed in on the
color section
now what it is doing is it is showing in
which country what different kind of
uh category wise movies are or shows
have been released like in Sri Lanka
documentaries have been released in
India action and adventure United States
action and adventure like this
now let's
put
a count of
the titles right so if you see 247
action and adventure movies or shows
have been released in United States
okay so this is one inference by this
particular report you can
identify
so let's see this report as
listed
in
by country
okay now let's create another report
we will call it as the per year
statistical report in this first I'll
put the release ears in the column
now
count of Netflix titles so this is the
count of Netflix titles per year so 2017
2016 14. and then count of Netflix
titles in the countries
this is the second bar chart okay now
what I'll do is I'll combine it into one
so one report
we are
moving in the bar creating the bar and
one in the line now I just have to
so we will click on the count of Netflix
titles by country right click Market
dual access so now as soon as you click
click this both the uh charts have been
combined and right click over here and
say synchronize access
okay
okay so now if you can see see right in
2017 you had uh 2 303 Netflix releases
across all categories and 1159
titles right one zero six three titles
in 2017 so this is a descending
representation of the count of titles
released per year across category and
across titles
so let's call this as
per year
starts
now let's create another report
number of shows
per title okay
so or or sorry per rating so we will
drag the rating column
and
we will
count of titles
and
unique count of titles and unique count
of show IDs
okay
one is bar and one is line
so this is a report which shows rating
wise titles and the show IDs
so in the tooltip you can see the
listing count of titles and show ID per
rating
okay so let's call it
shows per rating
now let's create another sheet
call it as
shows
by cast
so in this
what we're going to do is first drag the
cast column on the rows section you have
name all of all the cast and then we
drag the
show ID on the column section and put a
count D and sort it okay
you can remove the null cast and this is
your
sorted order and on the labels section
you can say show Mark labels and you
will see the count where an open care
has done the maximum then on Shahrukh
Khan
Shah so this is the details on this
sorted order that who has done how many
shows okay
then next is
shows by director similar to shows by
cast
drag
director into rows
or differently if you want to prepare
into columns and then count off
show ID
okay sort it
and you can actually filter out the null
director value
and this is the account put the label
so you can see Jan's Twitter has the
maximum shows
okay
then create another report
shows by category
now similarly drag the listed in
in the rows and show ID count
remove the null category
and sort
labels show Mark labels so International
movies are the highest category dramas
the next comedy International TV shows
this way
you have your category
now let's create a dashboard in which we
want to bring combine all these reports
and
take a common view so first let's drag
listed in by country
then
shows by director
also please let's set the size as
automatic
then let's drag shows by category
and shows by cast
now these four reports are on a single
dashboard we will link them to each
other so go to worksheet actions
add action
filter
select dashboard one
only select shows by category here
and in Target dashboard one
except shows by category keep everything
else
and in the source sheet just select
click select
click ok
okay now whatever category you will
select over here
that related category data will
automatically be shown in other reports
like see International movies across the
globe across countries directors of only
International movies who has done the
maximum
Johnny Tow and uh shows by cast right
that who has done the maximum
International movies or dramas
or comedies
travel has a maximum number of comedies
and then if you see the comedy movies uh
you know these are the count of comedy
movies released across the countries and
the who is the director
another a very interesting report which
you can prepare is that for example you
want to check in which country maximum
duration of uh your
maximum duration of
movies have been released so
first let's create a measure
remove this
okay
so if you see
maximum duration of the movies or the
entire Netflix content is maximum United
States then in India these many minutes
next is United Kingdom and you can also
change the colors
whatever you feel is as per your
standards or as per the convention you
can change the color combination
so there are multiple ways you can
generate reports and uh hope you have
understood how you can leverage such a
data to create your reports that's it if
you are an aspiring business analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns post Gadget program in
business analysis from Purdue University
in collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be a right choice for
more details choose the link mentioned
in the description box below today we
are going to talk about power bi what
are its features what are the basic
advantages of using a visualization tool
like power bi and we will talk about how
to install powerbo bi and other features
it provides and the basic setup
so let's discuss what's in it for us
today
now we will first talk about why power
bi you know why it's a popular tool and
what problem it solves what is power bi
uh and what are the primary features of
power VI uh which you can use in your
day-to-day data analytics visualizations
creating fancy reports creating
meaningful intelligent reports
for your organization for your personal
use for crunching numbers for generating
reports real time Etc
now the most popular tool for power bi
is the power bi desktop I'll show you
certain uh aspects of power bi desktop
and then I'll show you the steps how to
install power bi desktop on your machine
and then definitely power bi desktop is
a free tool provided by Microsoft but
then you can also subscribe for an
Enterprise version which is primarily
used by Enterprises for publishing their
data so we'll see the difference and
then overview of our dashboards which
can be created uh you know what kind of
dashboards can be created in power pi
so this is the agenda for us today
now why power bi so generally uh you
know visualization tools reporting tools
are required in order to create and
prepare and analyze meaningful data it
could be a data for an organization it
could be a social media platform data it
could be a data from iot devices but
something which needs to be analyzed and
some intelligent inferences and data
mining has to be done on top of it now
imagine there is today we are in a world
where terabytes of data and information
is getting generated on our
instantaneous basis on minute-by-minute
basis so it becomes very essential to
churn out something meaningful something
intelligent out of it in the market
there are a lot of other tools which are
available like clicks all tricks Tableau
and power bi so power bi is a Microsoft
product which is one of the most popular
products and it comes as a free to
download product Microsoft power bi
desktop which is available and I'll show
you a couple of ways how you can install
it on your machine but why power bi is
popular is because it provides a lot of
out of the box features drag and drop
features which we will talk about in our
subsequent sessions and you know classes
but today's session is primarily focused
on giving you guys an introduction on
what is the purpose of power bi and what
all problems it solve uh in the in the
real world so power bi allows you to
view analyze and visualize huge
quantities of data and the data could be
in any format Excel CSV text or it could
be a direct connection to a database
like SQL MySQL Azure Oracle anyone IBM
db2 so it supports n number of uh you
know data types or data sets and it's
very powerful in terms of data
connectivity
so it uses powerful compression
algorithms to import and Cachet the data
within the dot pbix file so it's as
convenient as a simple software if
suppose you import a data and then you
prepare a report and then you can easily
share the reports with your peers or
someone who's co-developing with you
either through Power bi cloud services
or even you can share the pbix file in
an email
or through any other means and you can
share the data set with the concern and
they can then work on the report
independently so there are different
ways there is no uh kind of a limitation
for you know working on power bi there
are multiple ways and it is very fast it
is the most fast uh tool to work with
Excel because definitely Excel is also a
Microsoft Technology so it works very
fast on Excel based data and gives you
numbers and Reporting at a very high
speed
so now once you have imported the data
power bi allows you to model the data
allows you to work intelligently on the
data it allows you to model data in a
way that if you are importing data from
multiple Excel sheets importing data
from multiple tables you can easily
create a relationship between those
tables or data sets in power bi and then
create visually appealing reports
meaningful reports as I've been
emphasizing and make sense out of that
data no data in silos is of any use data
in Silo means a single worksheet or a
single data set will not churn out any
meaningful information until unless you
basically join it clubbit merge it Union
it append it with some other data sets
because a single data set will never be
able to hold that much amount of
information which is generally required
for a you know important report
so it has easy drag and drop
functionality with features that allow
you to copy all formatting across
similar visualizations so just like in
Microsoft Excel we use format painter to
copy the format of one cell to another
similar features very very similar to
excel products or Microsoft product they
have provided that if you have applied a
a particular thing on a report you can
easily replicate that on an any other
report the font uh the header size the
background color you don't need to do it
again and again so there's a lot of
reusable features which are also
available okay now
as I said Excel is a Microsoft product
power bi is a Microsoft product so they
have intercompatibility you can publish
data from Excel to power bi now with the
latest developments and enhancements
as of today pixel has also plugged in a
new feature called powerpivot which I'll
uh show you later down the line but that
also allows you to do a quick analysis
no you can't create of course complex
reports or uh fancy reports like power
bi but Power pivot allows you to create
you know quick measures quick functions
quick calculations on your data quickly
only in Excel so it's an Excel plugin
but whereas you know you can power bi is
also compatible with Excel so when you
create a report in power bi it gives you
inbuilt feature to export your power bi
report into Excel format directly you
don't need to do any programming for it
also
you can easily publish when you publish
your power bi reports it allows you to
give some inbuilt intelligence of
analyzing your reports in Excel and it
gives you all those of all those
features of exporting your power bi
reports into Excel which is not
available in any other tool or otherwise
those tools have to create plugins
create add-ins and probably they might
charge for it but Power bi comes with
lot of out of the box features which are
very very helpful for analyzing data in
Excel and vice versa
Azure Cloud now Azure itself again is a
Microsoft cloud Tech stack so using
power bi with Azure allows you to
analyze and share large volumes of data
so Azure basically Azure database or
Azure Cloud servers are meant to hold
huge amount of data and power bi allows
you to have seamless connection you can
easily connect to Azure data Lake
you can reduce the time it takes to get
insights and increase collaboration
between business analysts data engineers
and data scientists so azure
data Lake becomes the central focal
point where all your analysts Engineers
can keep working on on the centralized
piece of data and churn out their
reports data scientists primarily job is
to keep the data in a structured way
optimized way optimize the input output
operations disk operations and memory
utilization so that the reports also get
churned out in a faster manner so every
uh you know every person has their own
role in order to give a quick
refreshable report a quick rendered
report any report which is taking huge
amount of time to get rendered will not
eventually be used by the business users
because then it does not solve the
purpose the report should be fast
reports should have uh you know
appropriate filters slices and dices you
should be able to you know create the
reports or dynamically or you should be
able to analyze visualize the data
dynamically so all those visualization
features are available in power bi and
it works seamlessly either it is small
data or huge data it allows that you to
work on those kind of data in a seamless
fashion
right so this is just a very uh quick uh
example of how our typical dashboard
looks like dashboard is nothing but you
know you have clubbed couple of multiple
reports on a single page and you know if
you change a filter uh uh a single
filter on the page all the reports will
honor that filter and the numbers will
change accordingly so if you see the in
this example there is a filter or a drop
down or product ID product name employee
name or supervisor or a date range so
whatever date range or filter you will
apply all the reports on this dashboard
will get changed based on the filter you
have selected so power bi allows you to
get insights from data and turn insights
into action to take data driven business
decision and that is the ultimate goal
of any visualization tool that is the
purpose for which visualization tools
are bought
and purchased by the organizations and
data is fed into them
Now power bi fetches data from Factory
sensors social media sources to get
access to real-time Analytics
so that you are always ready to make
timely business decisions so so
basically there is a a feature of live
connection or cut off data connection so
either you can work on data which is
deciding on a machine and you can just
work on the cutoff data like for example
it's there's a data which is available
for sales 2017 2018 and you're just
working on a historical data it's a cut
off data or it could be possible that
you want to be connected live uh to a
real-time iot based sensor based data or
social media data like Twitter Facebook
feeds or you know you're connected to
live Google worksheets that is also
possible you just need to publish your
Google sheet for a public domain embed
that you are into Power bi and then
whoever updates that Google sheet
automatically the power bi report will
also start honoring and consuming the
new data which is added in the uh Google
sheet so all those kind of real-time
streaming analytics is also possible and
that is one big feature and very
important feature of power bi which is
widely used and has a very huge uh you
know Market acceptance and Market
utilization
now what is power bi
power bi is a business analytics service
provided by Microsoft that lets you
visualize your data and share insights
right so earlier
you know uh
Microsoft used to have a technology
called ssas now they have replaced
actually ssas and SSRS with power bi so
basically you can use power bi on the
data which is there in your Excel or any
other data source and the power bi
service or power bi desktop basically
creates a connection to those data sets
and uh imported cache it and give you a
handle to it in order to work with it so
you can create these fancy meaningful
visualizations like for example there is
a geographical map if you are importing
data for a country or a continent or a
region power bi will automatically
detect that it's a geographical
information and give you a map with
latitude longitude information and you
just need to plot
your uh your numbers on the map either
you can use bubbles or or either you can
use triangles or whatever data structure
you you want to use but all the mapping
will be available geographically then
you can create pie charts which is shown
in this visualization you can create
dream maps you can create cards where
you know you can highlight the most
important numbers like sales total sales
of your company across all the regions
or the growth chart or the month on
month uh you know sales of your
organization or number of total number
of products or units sold so whatever is
important and to be highlighted for the
management to take any meaningful
decision or any insights you want to
share power bi visualization tool the
power bi visualization uh
uh chart allows you to drag and drop and
create wonderful reports okay
so what are the features of power bi so
power bi desktop is
something a standalone tool which you
need to install on your machine it
allows you to build reports by accessing
data easily you do not need Advanced
report
designing or query skills to build a
report though yes it is beneficial that
if you know uh some SQL programming
analytical programming or you are aware
of advanced features of any analytical
tool that might help you but that's not
a showstopper you can easily build
reports in quick turnaround time without
needing any technical background you
just need to have some analytical uh
mindset and you can create uh Savvy
visualization and you know analytical
reports
stream analytics as I mentioned you can
create a live connection uh with any
kind of data it could be iot it could be
media social media it could be Google
Docs it could be uh you know any other
kind of uh you know live connection it
could be a live database connection
itself so any insertions or updations or
deletions happening will automatically
reflect in your report
yes multiple data sources and that has
to be the primary criteria for any tool
to be popular if any visualization tool
is limited to certain data sets then you
know it will not be highly acceptable in
the market
and custom visualizations right so as I
showed you certain uh examples in the
past in the previous presentation uh
that feature is very important because
someone might want to look the kpis look
at the kpis from a different perspective
some management might want to look at
the kpis from a different perspective so
you need to you need to have that
capability to create different
visualization from the same data set now
let's take a look at how
to install power bi desktop on your
machine
so basically what you need to do is
you need to go to this URL
power bi dot microsoft.com en US desktop
okay
and you need to just
enter this
now you can download it for free so just
click over here
and
it will open Microsoft store so
basically now what Microsoft have done
in the latest operating systems is that
when you are trying to download you can
actually directly go to the Microsoft
store
and search for Power bi
so let's wait for a couple of seconds
right here so power bi desktop in
Microsoft store for me it's already
installed so it's asking me to open it
I'll open it in a while but for you for
anyone who is not installed he will see
the button of install over here and it
will automatically install in your
machine and then you can easily go and
open power bi desktop now if I click
open over here
now this is the
uh UI of the power bi desktop
I'm not going to go right now in
creating reports right away we will talk
about that in a subsequent session with
sample data sets and we will cover the
features of power bi desktop one by one
but this is what it is this is the whole
tool of power bi which is having the
visualization pane all the different
visualizations are you know can be
created from this pane then this is the
pane which allows you to select the data
data fields then there is a report view
data View and relationship view the data
model view where multiple relationships
you can create you can view the data in
the grid
of the tables which you will create and
the reports so you can create multiple
reports uh on multiple Pages you can
keep adding pages either you can drag
create multiple reports on a single page
and it will become a dashboard or you
can create separate independent reports
on the single page
and these are the menu options which we
will talk about how you can change color
scheming you can do data modeling you
can create new reports and you can also
transform data which is the biggest
feature extract transform and load the
data apply different logic changing data
types massaging the information creating
new joins appending the data you know
adding new columns etc etc uh we that is
what you can do in transform data so
this itself is a whole different world
it's a dedicated topic so we will talk
about that in our subsequent sessions so
what's in it for us today we will be
learning how to connect to data
different data types data files like
Excel PDF then what are the different
data importing modes and then I will
also show you practically different sets
how to import them in power bi and use
it for your visualization purpose now
what are the steps to connect to data so
now we will go directly into Power bi
and try to import one by one few most
commonly and popularly used data sets
which are most commonly used in a
day-to-day activity rest of course there
are power bi supports n number of data
sources but we will do something
practical on the most popular ones so
let's let's open our power bi
now this is my power bi and first I want
to show you that how can I import data
directly from a web page and import the
data now it is asking for a URL in order
to import data so what I have done is I
have created a Google Excel sheet with
simple data with rows and columns and
what I have done is I have shared this
sheet as published to web
okay so you just need to say publish to
the web the link as web page and
say done it's it's automatically
published and say link so copy the link
which you have published on the web copy
this link
and then go back to your tableau
paste that link over here and click ok
Now power bi will try to establish a
connection with this Google doc sheet
because it's published on the web
you need to wait for a while while it is
reading
okay now it has read one of the HTML
tables so I'll select this one now you
can see it has it is showing me a
preview of the table which is there on
my
Google sheet right it has 11 rows so it
has all showed all the 11 rows so now I
can go and transform this data because I
can see my headers are there starting
from the second row so there's an
opportunity for me to transform the data
so I'll go and transform it so that it
looks clean
okay so first is I need to remove the
first row which is the
null row remove the top rows
okay and then I need to use the first
row now as a header so you just click
this option use first row as headers
set so now if you see my row ID order ID
order date ship date all my data is now
ready so I can say close and apply
click apply changes
now this is an example of web data
import you can go and preview your data
right now the biggest advantage of this
data connection is that it's a live data
so for example I insert another row
let me change the order ID
some some I've sub change some basic
stuff and I
it's Auto saved
Ctrl s now I'll go to my tableau and
I'll refresh
now you can see as I refreshed my
power query editor I click refresh all
and I got my new row which is there in
the live data I got that fetched from my
okay I got that row the row number ID
number 12 so I have to say close and
apply
now you can see the new row the row
number 12 is now available in my new
data set in the data set because it's a
live connection it's a live connection
with the web based Google sheet okay so
this is one important way in which you
can import data
now let's try to import data from a text
file
now I have already prepared our text
file called
sub categories Dot txt
now let me just open it in a notepad now
it's a very plain simple file tab
separated file in which you have product
subcategory ID subcategory name and
product category key so basically to
which product category this particular
sub product belongs to right so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna go back to my
get data option
and I'm going to select text slash CSV
option
and I'm gonna select option mod product
subcategories Dot txt
okay so now power bi has identified that
it's a tab delimited file it has
recognized the headers
Etc right and I can now directly load
this file
okay
so now once the data is imported in
power bi it is like
irrelevant to me it's a composite data
in in Port I'm doing right so in my
presentation when I am talking about
importing data there are different
importing modes right import our data
import can happen through different ways
okay
one is direct query mode in which I
create a live connection to the database
which I'll also show you uh using MySQL
and Ms SQL server and also you can do a
composite mode in which you can have
data imported from Excel plus you can
have direct query modes so you can have
multiple uh modes to connect and create
a composite data model and that's what
we are doing right now in a practical so
what we are doing over here is one we
have imported data from the web second
we have to imported data from a text
table
now after after doing text now our next
task is to import from CSV let's try
another one so now I have imported
product subcategory
now I'll import
a CSV file so again I'll choose the
option Text slash CSV and now in this
CSV file let me open this CSV file and
show you what it is it
so this is a list of all my products
product key product sub category Key
Products uh stock keeping unit Etc a
simple CSV file and I'm gonna import
that
okay so now it is identified the
delimiter is comma rather than a tab and
it has already recognized the headers
correctly so I load it
okay so now my products are there
product subcategories are there for
product categories now what I have done
is I have created a Excel mode now so
now Excel I'm using to import my product
category
so now I have to click on the option of
import data from Excel and I'll say
product categories
select the sheet load
and now so my products product
categories product sub categories do
with different uh data storage types but
still now the data is imported into
Power bi is a composite data model now
another very important data type which
you can import is the PDF also right so
what I have done is I have created a PDF
called customers my customers data is
lying in a PDF so what I've done is I've
created a PDF
which has data for some columns are
there like you know customer key prefix
first name last name birth date marital
status gender email address annual
income total children etc etc so this is
the data set
which I have created in PDF so what I'm
going to do is
I'm going to select PDF now
and import customers.pdf
and see it has recognized my table on
page one which I am going to load
okay
you can rename this as PDF
table
okay so this basically these are the
different type of
data
types we have imported PDF Excel text
CSV and web page
now let's take a look at another
interesting data set which you want to
import is the my SQL Server data set
so what I have done is I've already
installed MySQL server on my local
instance and there's already a schema of
SQL live tutorial over there and I have
certain tables already
prepared over there like Department
employee Etc so my goal is now to import
this data or create a live connection
with this data set
now in order to import
my SQL database Connection in power bi
you need to First
download a
connector MySQL power bi connector so
you need to go to this link
and then click on download and install
the MySQL connector based on the
operating system you have you click on
download and install it
after you have done this go back to
Power bi
and then give
the IP address of the database in my
case it's there in this local machine
and the schema which I want to import is
SQL live tutorial so I'll give the name
click connect
okay now it's connected so now it is
asking me which particular tables you
want to create a connection with I am
choosing department and employee
and I'm just loading them
okay so now this is the exact data which
is there in the employee and Department
in MySQL okay so this is one example of
how to create connectivity between power
bi and MySQL
now I want to do the same thing using
SQL Server Microsoft SQL Server so I
have also installed Microsoft SQL server
on my machine
and I have used the SQL Express so this
is the name of my server so which I'll
copy the server name
and
go to get data
select SQL Server
and for now database is optional I can
say direct query click ok
now it is showing me what all tables I
can import so in my SQL Server tutorial
in my SQL Server I have
I have these three tables customers
employee attrition Olympic events so I
can use probably the customers one which
is
now you can see this is the data the
customer's data which is lying in my SQL
Server okay so I can preview it and load
it
so now you can you can preview the data
in uh Power bi that is this is the data
so I can rename his customers from
mssql
and this is from
MySQL
and
okay so now
this is not the only data
sets you can import now if you take a
look at the options which power bi gave
what different type and variations of
data it can it has compatibility to
import from
okay so we can just take a look at the
categorization on the left hand side
first there are five ways like Excel
text XML Json is also possible you can
evenly directly import an entire folder
and within the folder whatever uh data
types of files are there it will detect
it PDF power key or even SharePoint
folder which is itself Microsoft uh
technology then different kind of
databases SQL server and MySQL we just
saw but it's not only limited to this
you can connect to Microsoft Access
ssas Oracle database IBM db2 postgres
site base teradata and then sap
databases Amazon redshift Impala vertica
Snowflake and N number of databases
which are there in the market today
Amazon
Etc
then it also allows you to connect with
its own power platforms power bi
platforms data mods power bi data flows
dataverse Etc
Azure there are different kind of
storage
mechanisms in Azure and Azure itself is
a Microsoft Technology so it has a
compatibility of a lot of azure uh based
data storages like Azure SQL database
blob storage uh Azure data breaks right
Azure HD insights path so if you have
those kind of services running on your
observed cloud services you can even
import them over here
now online services
like you know you have erps running uh
or some data which is shared on the
internet if you want to import it uh
that is also possible through certain
products uh Dynamics 365 Microsoft
Exchange online Salesforce Google
analytics Adobe analytics GitHub
LinkedIn sales if you want to do some
analysis of some social networking uh
you know feeds that also you can import
then other miscellaneous are also their
web-based hive R script python script if
there's something to import get data
from uh Google Sheets like we store one
example in our video right now so there
are multiple options available
now once you have imported the data
which is relevant to you in hours of
sequence sessions we will see how to
create relationships but just giving you
a glimpse that whatever data you are
importing power bi Auto detect certain
relationships and it will create for you
but then you can go and manually also
change so this is the composite data
model which is getting created in the
back end while you are importing the
data you can easily go and manage these
relationships either keep them as is you
can delete and create new ones manually
so there is no limitation in that
so this is what we have witnessed we
have imported data from different files
types data types and then you know we
have tried once it is imported into uh
Power bi then there is no limitation of
how you use it you can create
visualization across different data sets
and then create your
standard reports
so this is the example of importing data
from web importing data from a database
from a PDF
and then once you have data you can
shape and combine data you can basically
do what whatever transformation you want
to do you want to make joins merge the
data so for example if we go back to our
power bi and if I go back to my
transform data section
now as I have now different data sets
available with me I have I can do any
kind of you know operation
transformation on the data right uh
so like I showed you I uh upgraded the
header row because one of the imported
data was not showing the header
correctly uh or this columns like this
exact one column is extra I can remove
the column
right all those Transformations whatever
I do in the back end gets captured in
the applied steps section right
this is the customer data you can create
uh you can merge it you can append it uh
you know with other data sets right
let's for example I want to create a
merge data set of my categories and
subcategories so I can say mer selectors
two data sets and say merge queries as
new
and
I can select product categories and
products are categories select
product category key on both the sides
and then they do a left Auto Zone so
whatever product categories are there
I'll get the subcategories associated
with it and I'll create a new table
which will have
now I have the table which has the
category and the subcategory and
subcategory in one table itself so I can
rename it now to as
category
sub category
table it's a merge basically it's a join
between category and subcategory now I
have a common table right and I can
close and apply
so imagine I have created a new table
which is imported created from one data
set is which is Excel page another data
set which is text based
see this category subcategory table so
now I can use it
the way I want in my visualization
reports so that's what the presentation
says right that once you have uh the
imported data you can shape you can
combine you can adjust you can do
whatever transformation you want to do
and create your visualization okay so
what topics we are going to cover today
we are going to talk about different
types of data modeling and the most
important part
and aspect of data modeling is the
cardinality the cardinality which you
basically decide after reviewing the
nature of data and after you've imported
it what kind of cardinality you have to
basically highlight right and there are
different type of cardinalities which
you might have heard earlier also if you
are from PL SQL background like one is
to one one is too many Etc we will we
will talk about that
now what are the different types of data
modeling now dimensional data modeling
is one of the most popular and most uh
you know widely used uh modeling in
dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers
Etc that will change less frequently as
compared to the sales transactions
because transactions are happening every
day every minute so sales is a more fast
changing data set in dimensional
modeling which is in the terminology of
data uh is also called as a fat and
customer store product which are like
more of static data and less changeable
data is sometimes called a diamond
ancient so this is a typical dimensional
data model which is typically used uh
sometimes right and then there is
another model which is relational model
this is a typical model which we have
been using in database design like you
know primary key foreign key
relationships so for example you have a
customer who has purchased a product so
probably he might have the customer
might have the details of the product
which is processed and you will make a
join between customer and product table
and even you can make a join between
product or product type or customer or
product types customer table will also
have a key to the product type so this
is less conducive for reporting but it
is more of a transactional relational
model but of course this is also
feasible but from the power bi
perspective when we talk about reporting
and visualization this is the most
extensively used dimensional data model
and this is what we are going to see in
our example now so what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna show you certain data sets
first we will prepare and create certain
offer data sets and then we will Import
in our sample power bi and then slowly
slowly we will create the relationships
now one important thing which you need
to understand that in power bi if you go
to Power bi there is an option that that
power bi Auto detect new relationships
after data is loaded and import
relations from the data source on first
load so for example if you are importing
the data from a database where you have
already defined the primary keys and the
foreign key relationships so uh that is
the first option which power bi will
Auto detect and secondly if suppose you
are importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
power bi detects a common column key
columns it will auto detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship
menu manage relationship menu in power
bi which I'm gonna show you okay so if I
I open a power bi and this is where the
option lies go to file
go to options and setting options
data load
and these are the two options which are
by default check you can uncheck it and
auto and manually prepare relationships
there's no limitation to that but if you
uh keep it checked then power bi will do
its job to detect the relationships okay
now coming to the next important factor
cardinality now before I start playing
around with my data and start showing
you certain relationships it's very
important to understand these four types
of cardinalities one is many to one
right so basically
many to one means that many orders
contain data of One customer so per
order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one-to-man relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many-to-one
relationship
okay
second other cardinality is one is to
one one is to one relationship is only
applicable when you are saying it's an
extension of the current table so for
example in one table you have employee
details and you are extending the
details of the employee in another table
like employee address employee ID so
that is like one is to one there is no
multiple records of a single employee in
the address table only one employee ID
exists right
now one is too many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one so in
customer table only one customer record
exists per customer and one customer can
place many orders for multiple products
and can also have multiple delivery
addresses so that way this is a typical
one is to many relationship we will be
seeing this example also in our sample
data set
and last is the many-to-many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you practice practically and in our
case we will see that like for example
you have placed an order for a
particular product uh you know but there
are multiple fulfillments which has
happened so suppose you made order for
10 products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically you the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order ID might have a multiple
fulfillments for the same order ID so
there will be a multi many to many
relationship which I'll show you
practically so now with this background
let's
start importing our data now the first
important thing which we need to import
is the Master data so first I'll import
all my master Dimensions which is uh
which I'm going to you know use in my
example so first is the customers table
customers data
so this is the customer details the
customer key prefix first name last name
birth date marital status and gender
some redundant columns are also present
but we'll remove it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes
okay so now this is my customers data
with the relevant columns and the key
per customer customer key
now there's no relationship in this
model right now right because only
single table is there and the associate
data is only imported now let me also
import my another important master table
is the products
select the products data product key
product sub category product SKU product
name model name product description
color size so just see all the relevant
information only specific to the product
is available so I'll import it
okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales table
now I I'm assuming that power bi have
Auto detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
power bi what relations power bi has
Auto detected let's first say check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click this
join now what it has done is it has
created a join of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
place many orders right and that is that
it is detected by the quality of the
data and the data sampling which power
bi has done you can also reverse this
relationship here I can select customers
and I can select sales now it has become
one too many so that you can also do
manually so that is what I said whatever
power bi is detected it is up to the
description of power bi internal uh
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's
change the relationship so one is too
many means from One customer and many
sales orders
similarly let's see what has happened at
the product side
of the relationship
similarly power bi many sales orders for
one product you can for simplicity's
sake you can say products
sales
product key is the join now just focus
one more thing please also see the the
column on which the join is is the grade
column grade out column product key is
also here and product key is also there
and it is what we wanted so one is too
many relationship from product to sales
table and act
now looks fine this is something which
is looking logical and probably now we
can
proceed further to create a report
now let me explain the cross filtering
with an example
now for example I want to check in a
report
that what is the count of products which
uh which a particular customer has
ordered
okay so what I'll do is I'll select the
product count of product name
now if you see
and for each customer in front of each
customer name the count is coming as 293
293 it is getting repetitive because
because there is a one-way filter
Direction filter between customers and
sales and sales and products right so
this join
is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go here
I'll first open my sales table
we can also open it here let's make
click it says okay now if I click OK you
can see the single arrow is changed to
Double Arrow it means it's a it's a both
site filter
So when you say a both side filter it
means that implicitly within power bi
you can imagine that all the product
columns now will get appended because of
both ways filter you have applied and if
you go to your report now see the change
of the numbers now 40 20 so the total
count of products across all my
customers come out to be 293. now the
report looks uh correct if I change the
relationship from back to single between
product and sales then you can't make a
join between customers and products
basically you can't derive the product
count from the product table see this
if you have to live with it then you
would have to go to the sales table get
the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct okay
so if you want a report in which you
want the count of product name
and even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the
direction of the filter which is from
single to both so this is a typical
example they where you want to use a
two directional filter
now let's proceed further and import
other data set in order to give show you
another example
now I want to show you an example of
one is to
1.
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is there
so I'm loading the customer details now
you see it has Auto detected a one is to
one relationship
but what is the meaning of one is to one
means One customer key only has one
entry in customer details there is no
multiple entry so if you click this
button
it's a one is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now easily
associate a
email address with the first name you
will get one is to one
record
so now you can see that with one is to
one relationship
with the first name I have Associated
the email ID and for each email ID
there is a Associated first name method
so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count
so in this report what we have done is
uh if you click over here so the first
name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one relationship
and then
and if you drag
the customer key
report takes time to render and even if
you can
so this is the reporting output you have
the customer key first name associated
email address and the count of product
names uh which the customer has ordered
now this is an example of 1 is to 1.
now I want to show you an example of
many too many now for that I'll import
my fulfillment data set
foreign
data set there is a column for
order number so basically what I'll do
is I'll drag order number from here to
here
okay so now what has uh
power bi detected
I'll do one thing I'll select sales over
here
fulfillment over here and order number
to odd number
okay so it's a many-to-many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order now
many to many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for
both ways cross filter detection uh a
Direction but you can you can check that
but definitely uh Power bi shows a
warning that this relationship has
cardinality to many to many and this
should only be used if it is expected
that neither column contains unique
values okay so we know that fact that's
why we are accepting this relationship
as many to many because we know there
are multiple order numbers over here in
the sales table which are mapped to the
multiple order numbers in the
Fulfillment table we'll click ok
now you want to keep the uh
direction as both ways or One Direction
that is up to you the way you want to
map the report so I can double click
over here
and you can even click so now you can
select from which way single filter you
want from fulfillment to sales or sales
to fulfillment I'll prefer sales to
fulfillment and click ok
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to shortlist one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many too many
now if I show you further relationships
which you can keep on adding like for
example I have a uh the example of
territories
now in which particular territory the
sales was done
map it over here
okay so now it's a typical one is too
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you have
uh details of returns
now this is another transactional table
which is about the orders which have
been returned rather than being you know
returned by the customers so you have a
product key
uh so automatically power bi has
detected a relationship between the
product key and the product uh table
right and even if you can join the
territory key in which territory the
return has happened
right so mostly the most common
relationship which you will observe is
the one is too many because
as I told earlier the most common
relational model is the dimensional
model uh the static data the slow
changing Dimensions the scds are the
master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I
talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the territory stable sorry uh the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data model now so far what we have done
as per our last session is that we did
data modeling on the different data sets
which we had imported in power bi like
products sales data returns fulfillment
customer details uh and customer Master
data calendar details Etc so in the last
session we prepared a data model and
established the relationships between
these different and data sets like one
is to one one is too many many to one
one is to one Etc and we saw the
examples now once our relational model
is prepared our data model is prepared
now our next activity is to create
certain additional columns which we want
to derive basis the data which we have
imported
so for example I'll start with my
product data set now in my product data
set I want to introduce a column which
basically
categorizes that if any product which
has a color uh you know red black or
gray I am going to tag it as a colored
product rest I'm gonna say not a colored
product right so all these are like
example of byte type product skus so for
that now in order to introduce a new
column you just need to do what you need
to select the table in the data grid go
to the table tools and say new column
okay so column will get appended to the
rightmost part and you will start seeing
a uh formula section typical to like you
get in your Excel now I'm gonna say that
the name of my column is going to be
byte type color okay and I'm just
creating a if condition if
product
color
is equal to
black
okay
or
or if it is equal to red
or if it is equal to
Gray
then
say yes it's a colored product I'll say
no
okay so now you can see this is the
product color red and black they are
saying byte type color Yes blue is no
multi is no etc etc so this is a classic
example of an if and else condition
based conditional column okay so you can
create such columns now second column
custom column which I want to create is
I'm going to call as discount
now this is the pricing of my products I
want to associate certain discounts
which I am ready to give to my customers
this is the product category like what
is the pricing of the category again I'm
going to use make use of if else but in
a nested way so if I am saying if my
product
price is less than 100
then I will give
zero percent of
uh zero percentage of discount so 0 into
product price just to keep it consistent
now I'm seeing
else
if less than 100 and 0 else I'll check
again that
if
the price is
less than
500 then I'm ready ready to give one
percent discount
on the product price
else
I'll move further so like this I have
created a formula
so what I'm saying is if product price
is less than 100 gives zero percent if
it is less than 500 then give one
percent less than two thousand then one
point five percent less than three
thousand then two percent and otherwise
else less than three thousand if it two
percent else three percent right now
after this column is created
now you can check right so this C the
product price for this particular
product it is less than 100 so that's
why there is no discount it is
uh between 100 to 200 then this has been
given a one percent discount so like
this all the discount column is now
calculated now this column is available
just like a regular column in my product
table
now after this I'll go to my sales table
now in sales table I want to
identify and uh
create a column called as cost
there is no
product cost column over here so that
will be derived
so let's create a column
called as cost
and it is derived by order quantity
into now the cost of the product
is in the product table and I know I
have already created a relationship
between product and sales table
so I just need to select the product
cost column now only keyword which I
have to use in power bi is the related
keyword so this will pick up the
relation
and now for this particular sale order
the cost has already been derived so
this order number this is the cost for
which uh the product has is the costing
of the product for this particular order
foreign
now I'm gonna create another conditional
column over here called as
order status
I'm saying if
any order whose order quantity is
greater than 2
then for my organization it's an urgent
order
else it is a
normal order
oh sorry
lost it
so this is my
order status column and I have my order
quantity
urgent or normal
so any order which has order quantity 1
is normal any order which is having
order quantity as greater than
2 is
urgent you can see this
so there's a
this whole power bi
uh tabs and sheets allow you to also
review the data what you're doing so
it's very convenient
now
I have my sales data now what I want to
bring within the sales is my discount
column so here also I want to bring the
discount which I have created
so I'll say discount
[Music]
will be order quantity
into
related
product discount right so the discount
calculated column which I had created
under products I'll bring over here
now I am creating the order level
discount so if you see for this
particular order there's a 25 uh
uh you know for 25 rupee discount at the
cost is hundred thousand rupees okay
and what is the order price now so I
have taken the order cost the discount
now I have to create a column call as
price order price so that will be
again order quantity
into related
price which is per product
price enter
okay so now I have the cost the discount
and the price right available with me
now I want to
calculate the total
uh
total revenue total profit and loss
right
per order how much
so first I'll calculate per order how
much revenue I am generating so now I
have to generate a column called as
Revenue
revenue is price
minus discount
so 1700 minus 25
1700 minus 25 2071 minus 42 and if I
want to calculate the profit per order
then it is
Revenue
Minus cost
okay so now you can see you know typical
custom columns calculated columns which
you have created are all playing around
with the number numeric values numeric
data primarily and trying to give
inferences into per order cost discount
per order price revenue and profit so
typical calculation columns which I have
prepared in front of you
now let's take a look at other different
variations of custom columns I'll create
certain columns for text based custom
columns calculated columns using Text
data
so I'm now moving towards my customer
table in which I have customer key
prefix first name last name birth date
marital status and gender
now I want to create a new column in
which I want to derive the age of each
customer as of today right so I'll use
another function a date function called
as
date div
now date div so I want the difference
between the birth date of the customer
and as of today
in years
okay so this customer as of today 68
year old one is 74 68 57 Etc so this is
one derivation of a calculated column of
age
let's take another example now this is a
text based column where I want to
derive the full name of the customer
now here I'll say first
lowercase in lower case I'll concatenate
the prefix
then ampersand
space
ampersand
first name
Ampersand space
ampersand
last name
and closing brackets
Etc
full name
okay so this is an example of full name
in low cases
now another
calculated column conditional column at
the customer level
I want to identify a flag which says who
is my Target customer base is the
demographics shared over here Target
customer
so I'll say
if
the marital status is equal to
m
and
total children
hurry
and total children annual income
so okay so let me change the logic a bit
so marital status is M and
age
is
less than
these customers are my Target customers
okay so I would say
yes
else no
say this
he is a marital status is married Logan
Diaz and age is less than 50 else
everyone so if I try to filter
so these are the my Target customers
69 out of 1178 so this is just a
conditional column but a logical
condition an example which I am trying
to highlight over here
okay now
let's look at certain calendar
date oriented columns calculated columns
very typical like now I have a simple
date column now I'll keep adding certain
columns which are you know which help
you which will help you understand how
we can uh
you know do some calculations on the
dates so like for example I want a date
which is 12 days after the current date
the date in the column so just simple 12
Days After
select the date and add 12.
now if you see the date format you can
go and change the format at the top
and if whatever you feel like like this
now see 12 days after first Jan 2015 is
13 Jan 2005. you can go and change the
format and other details
let me also show you if I go to my cost
and other columns I can go and change
the format this is like a currency cost
is currency so I can go and
select the
change the currency type and
you can even show the dollar value or
whatever currency type it is
so for numbers you can do currency or
text or dates you can select the format
so this is available at the column tools
level
now in customers
like we had our
column of full name so now what all
things are available format as text okay
data type text so very minimal options
are there with date you have options of
the date format
now next
I want a column which defines the expiry
date okay so eight months prior
to the
expiry date within which is coming up in
eight months so I'll create a column
called as eight months expiry
and then there is a e date function I'll
use that I'll use my
date in the data set
comma I'll say eight so now this date
column will append eight months to my
actual date and again I can go and
change the format
correct
now another important column like I want
to know the date name
so I'll use a function called as
format
and I'll select my calendar date column
and I'll say give me the DDD
format of it so it will give me the day
name the day the day name of on that
particular date
next
years in between
so I want the years in between the
today's date and the date of my calendar
so equal to
D Def
the calendar date
comma today
comma year
end
seven years 2015 to 2022
then last date of the month
so if I want what is the last date of
this particular calendar month
I will use a function EO month which is
there and label in the
power bi so I'll say
last date of the month
equal to
e o month
then
just select the calendar CSV date
comma
0 in months and enter
change the format
then similarly start of the month
so I'll use a function called start of
month
so for for all January dates end of the
month is 31st Jan and start of the month
will remain first of Jan
change the format
foreign
next I want to know what is the weak
number of that particular date so now
there is an inbuilt function called
weak number week num and just pass the
date and you will get
the weak number first week of the year
second week of the year Etc
now another very
good example is whether the weak
day is a weekday or a weekend right so
what is it's a weak type okay
so I'll check I'll put a if condition
and there is a function called weekday
and I'll pass the calendar
if it is less than 6
it means it's a weekday as it's a
weekend
so all Saturday
and Sunday D names will come as weekends
or else everything else will come as
weekly that's it if you are an aspiring
business analyst looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learn postgraduate
program in business analysis from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be a right
choice for more details choose the link
mentioned in the description box below
now today we will discuss
relationships
and different kind of data models within
power bi based on the structure of data
you're importing
okay so what topics we are going to
cover today we are going to talk about
different types of data modeling and the
most important part
and aspect of data modeling is the
cardinality the cardinality which you
basically decide after reviewing the
nature of data and after we've imported
it what kind of cardinality you have to
basically highlight right and there are
different type of cardinalities which
you might have heard earlier also if you
are from PL SQL background like one is
to one one is too many Etc we will we
will talk about that
now what are the different types of data
modeling now dimensional data modeling
is one of the most popular and most uh
you know widely used uh modeling in
dimensional data modeling you have
Master data uh like for example customer
data date store data product data so
these are like you know uh less
frequently changing data sets so there
is an organization right and you have
set of customers their email ID phone
numbers
Etc that will change less frequently as
compared to the sales transactions
because transactions are happening every
day every minute so sales is a more fast
changing data set in dimensional
modeling which is in the terminology of
data is also called as a fat and
customer store product which are like
more of static data and less changeable
data is sometimes called a diamond
patient so this is a typical dimensional
data model which is typically used uh
sometimes right and then there is
another model which is relational model
this is a typical model which we have
been using in database design like you
know primary key foreign key
relationships so for example you have a
customer who has purchased a product so
probably he might have the customer
might have the details of the product
which is processed and you will make a
join between customer and product table
and even you can make a join between
product or product type or customer or
product type customer table will also
have a key to the product type so this
is less conducive for reporting but it
is more of a transactional relational
model but of course this is also
feasible but from the power bi
perspective when we talk about reporting
and visualization this is the most
extensively used dimensional data model
and they this is what we are going to
see in our example now so what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna show you certain data
sets first we will prepare and create
certain upper data sets and then we will
Import in our sample power bi file and
then slowly slowly we will create the
relationships
now one important thing which you need
to understand that in power bi if you go
to Power bi there is an option that that
power bi Auto detect new relationships
after data is loaded and import
relations from the data source on first
load so for example if you are importing
the data from a database where you have
already defined the primary keys and the
foreign key relationships so uh that is
the first option which power bi will
Auto detect and secondly if suppose you
are importing two different kind of data
sets one is Excel one is csb and if
power bi detects a common column key
columns it will auto detect a
relationship which you can go and later
change modify manage in your
relationship
menu manage relationship menu in power
bi which I'm going to show you okay so
if I open a power bi and this is where
the option lies go to file
go to options and setting options
data load
and these are the two options which are
by default check you can uncheck it and
auto and manually prepare relationships
there's no limitation to that but if you
uh keep it checked then power bi will do
its job to detect the relationships okay
now coming to the next important factor
cardinality
now before I start playing around with
my data and start showing you certain
relationships it's very important to
understand these four types of
cardinalities one is many to one right
so basically
many to one means that many orders
contain data of One customer so per
order one customer is there so from
customer to order or product or delivery
address it's a one-to-man relationship
and from the other side from order to
customer perspective it's a many-to-one
relationship
okay
second other cardinality is one is to
one one is to one relationship is only
applicable when you are saying it's an
extension of the current table so for
example in one table you have employee
details and you are extending the
details of the employee in another table
like employee address employee ID so
that is like one is to one there is no
multiple records of a single employee in
the address table only one employee ID
exists right
now one is too many as I said is the
reverse side of many is to one so in
customer table only one customer record
exists per customer and one customer can
place many orders for multiple products
and can also have multiple delivery
addresses so that way this is a typical
one is to many relationship we will be
seeing this example also in our sample
data set
and last is the many-to-many
relationship now many to many is a very
typical example so which I'm going to
show you practice practically and in our
case we will see that like for example
you have placed an order for a
particular product uh you know but there
are multiple fulfillments which has
happened so suppose you made order for
10 products but at the back end when the
company is fulfilling it is first
fulfilling the first two products then
the rest three so basically you the
Fulfillment is happening in batches so
one order
ID might have a multiple fulfillments
for the same order ID so there will be a
multi many to many relationship which
I'll show you practically so now with
this background let's
start importing our data now the first
important thing which we need to import
is the Master data so first I'll import
all my master Dimensions which is uh
which I'm gonna you know use in my
example so first is the customers table
customers data
so this is the customer details the
customer key prefix first name last name
birth date marital status and gender
some redundant columns are also present
but we'll remove it
so my customer data is loaded now
today's session is all about this
section of modeling so we will keep our
Focus over here
okay now some columns probably some
blank columns are there I can select
them and say delete from model
yes
okay so now this is my customers data
with the relevant columns and the key
per customer customer key
now there's no relationship in this
model right now right because only
single table is there and the associate
data is only imported now let me also
import my another important master table
is the products
select the products data product key
product sub category product SKU product
name model name product description
color size so just see all the relevant
information only specific to the product
is available so I'll import it
okay now see there's no relationship
between product and customers directly
because until unless a customer makes an
order places an order for a particular
product there is no join right so now
between these two tables the most
important now another table which will
now make sense is the sales order table
sales table
now I I'm assuming that power bi have
Auto detected the relationship now you
can see that because I've already uh
ticked that check box now let's see what
power bi what relations power bi has
Auto detected let's first say check the
relation between customer and sales I'll
double click this
join now what it has done is it has
created a join of many to one
between sales and customer so what does
that mean is that one customer has can
place many orders right and that is that
it is directed by the quality of the
data and the data sampling which power
bi has done you can also reverse this
relationship here I can select customers
and I can select sales now it has become
one too many so that you can also do
manually so that is what I said whatever
power bi is detected it is up to the
description of power bi internal uh
configuration and algorithm but you can
go and change it so this is now you can
this is by default active so we want to
keep it active One customer many sales
orders cross filter Direction means that
only from customers to sales is the
filter applicable not reverse I'll come
to this with my another example but
first let's
change the relationship so one is too
many means from One customer and many
sales orders
similarly let's see what has happened at
the product side
of the relationship
similarly power bi many sales orders for
one product you can for simplicity's
sake you can say products
sales
product key is the join now just focus
one more thing please also see the the
column on which the join is is the grade
column grade out column product key is
also here and product key is also there
and it is what we wanted so one is too
many relationship from product to sales
table and act
now looks fine this is something which
is looking logical and probably now we
can
proceed further to create a report
now let me explain the cross filtering
with an example
now for example I want to check in a
report
that what is the count of products which
uh which a particular customer has
ordered
okay so what I'll do is I'll select the
product count of product name
now if you see
and for each customer in front of each
customer name the count is coming as 293
293 it is getting repetitive because
because there is a one-way filter
Direction filter between customers and
sales and sales and products right so
this join
is single sided it means that from
customer to product you can't find a
relationship because it's a single side
cross filter right what does this if I
change it to both it means that it is
equal to a join between product and
sales and every product detail now is
appended to the sales table so if I want
to make you visualize this you need to
go here
I'll first open my sales table
we can also open it here let's make
click it says okay now if I click OK you
can see the single arrow is changed to
Double Arrow it means it's a it's a both
side filter
So when you say a both side filter it
means that implicitly within power bi
you can imagine that all the product
columns now will get appended because of
both ways filter you have applied and if
you go to your report now see the change
of the numbers now for T20 so the total
count of products across all my
customers come out to be 293. now the
report looks uh correct if I change the
relationship from back to single between
product and sales then you can't make a
join between customers and products
basically you can't derive the product
count from the product table see this
if you have to live with it then you
would have to go to the sales table get
the product key and get the value of
count of product key but that is not
correct okay
so if you want a report in which you
want the count of product name
and even if you want a count of distinct
product name so this will not come
correctly you would have to go and
change the
direction of the filter which is from
single to both so this is a typical
example there where you want to use a
two directional filter
now let's proceed further and import
other data set in order to give show you
another example
now I want to show you an example of
one is to
1.
so I have another table which is called
customer details so the key in this
table is again customer key but only
email address annual income total
children education level Etc other
details of the customer is there
so I'm loading the customer details now
you see it has Auto detected a one is to
one relationship
what is the meaning of one is to one
means One customer key only has one
entry in customer details there is no
multiple entry so if you click this
button
it's a one is to one and the cross
filter can be both or single doesn't
matter because one customer will have
only one value you can make this as
active okay and if you go to the
customer report table you can now easily
associate a
email address with the first name you
will get one is to one
record
so now you can see that with one is to
one relationship
with the first name I have Associated
the email ID and for each email ID
there is a Associated first name method
so this is an example of
one is to one relationship so in this
example what we have explained is that
for each customer there is an Associated
customer detail right uh so you have the
first name email address education level
homeowner occupation and total children
count
so in this report what we have done is
uh if you click over here so the first
name and the email address okay so
there's a one is to one relationship
and then
and if you drag
the customer key
report takes time to render and even if
you can
so this is the reporting output you have
the customer key first name associated
email address and the count of product
names uh which the customer has ordered
now this is an example of one is to 1.
now I want to show you an example of
many too many now for that I'll import
my
fulfillment data set
foreign
data set there is a column for
order number so basically what I'll do
is I'll drag order number from here to
here
okay so now what has uh
power bi detected
I'll do one thing I'll select sales over
here
fulfillment over here and order number
to odd number
okay so it's a many-to-many relationship
so it means that per order I have
created multiple batches to fulfill that
particular order now
many-to-many relationship is a
definitely a candidate for both ways
cross filter detection uh a Direction
but you can you can check that but
definitely uh Power bi shows a warning
that this relationship has cardinality
to many to many and this should only be
used if it is expected that neither
column contains unique values okay so we
know that fact that's why we are
accepting this relationship as many to
many because we know there are multiple
order numbers over here in the sales
table which are mapped to the multiple
order numbers in the Fulfillment table
we'll click ok
now you want to keep the uh
direction as both ways or One Direction
that is up to you the way you want to
map the report so I can double click
over here
and you can even click so now you can
select from which way single filter you
want from fulfillment to sales or sales
to fulfillment I'll prefer sales to
fulfillment and click ok
okay now we have our all our different
kind of relationships over here uh which
we have tried to shortlist one to many
many to one one to one which is uh this
example and many too many
now if I show you further relationships
which you can keep on adding like for
example I have uh uh the example of
territories
now in which particular territory the
sales was done
map it over here
okay so now it's a typical one is too
many relationship because territory is
my master table uh where I have a static
list of continent country region and it
is mapped to the uh territories which
are for in which my orders have been
placed so it's a typical one is too many
so that way you know you can keep on
adding data then you have
uh details of returns
now this is another transactional table
which is about the orders which have
been returned rather than being you know
returned by the customers so you have a
product key
and so automatically power bi has
detected a relationship between the
product key and the product uh table
right and even if you can join the
territory key in which territory the
return has happened
right so mostly the most common
relationship which you will observe is
the one is too many because
as I told earlier the most common
relational model is the dimensional
model uh the static data the slow
changing Dimensions the scds are the
master tables and the most frequent
changing are the fact tables so if I
talk about a typical dimensional model
the Fulfillment table sales table and
the territory stable sorry uh the
Fulfillment table sales table and my
returns table are the fact tables of my
data model
hello and welcome to the lesson
formatting conditional formatting and
important functions in this lesson we
will learn about custom formatting how
to use conditional formatting and
formulas and Implement logical
statistical and mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above Target below Target and met Target
as a data set can be huge and complex
differentiating each value manually
would consume a lot of effort and time
here comes the Excel features such as
formatting and conditional formatting
which enables us to perform this task
easily
formatting as the name suggests helps us
to format the data using different
techniques making the data easy to read
in the required format and analyze them
the right formatting technique applied
to the worksheets can help the users
present the data efficiently conditional
formatting a type of formatting helps us
visually explore and analyze data detect
critical issues and identify patterns
and trends conditional formatting helps
to add patterns and Trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formula Etc
at times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set
Excel provides a large number of logical
statistical and mathematical functions
such as vlookup hlookup and if not rank
quartile and many more that can help the
users to perform calculations ranging
from basic to complex operations
these inbuilt functions help us to
manage data and perform descriptive
statistical analysis
Excel also offers a wide range of
important formulas that help to perform
many common tasks these formula may be
as simple as basic addition or it could
be a complex combination of inbuilt
excel functions before going into
details let us start this lesson by
defining the objectives of the lesson
the worksheets appear more polished and
easy to read if proper formatting
techniques are applied to it
we can format the cells in Microsoft
Excel manually by selecting fonts font
color font size background colors and
borders we can also use numerous
predefined table Styles or quick styles
to quickly format a table automatically
this is the basic formatting in Excel
if these built-in functions do not meet
our needs or do not display the data in
the format that we require we can create
our own custom format in this topic we
will focus on custom formatting in Excel
let's say we want to display one million
five hundred and thirty two thousand as
1.53 M or the first of January 2016 date
with a weekday as the first Friday
January 2016. here we can use custom
formatting feature of excel let's see
how we can accomplish this in Excel
in this lesson we shall consider the
following fields from our master table
dates order ID
product salesman region number of
customers net sales and profit and loss
here in the given worksheet we have a
column named net sales
suppose we want to display the values of
net sales in terms of thousands for
example
7164 should be displayed at 7.16 k
select the entire column for net sales
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in the numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format sales dialog box appears from the
category list select the type as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number 0 decimal zero zero comma
open double quote capital K close double
quote
here number is the digit holder with
thousand comma separation
each comma after decimal 0 0
indicate divide value by one thousand
the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places
the K component displays a literal K
character to denote thousands
here we can see the preview in sample
box the value shown is 7.16 K
finally click OK button
the values in column net sales are now
displayed in terms of thousands
now let us consider another example of
date formatting
in the column dates we have a date value
written as first Jan 2012. we want to
display it as first Sunday Jan 2012.
first select the column containing dates
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cell dialog box appears
from the category list select the type
as custom
in the type text box enter DD dash dddd
dash mmm YY
here d stands for date m stands for
month and y stands for year
the first 2dd is the date
the next four dddd is for weekday say
Thursday
then mmm is for the month in short form
and YY is for year
here we can see in the preview in the
sample box the value shown is one Sunday
Jan 12.
finally click on OK button
thus the custom formatting helps us in
changing the appearance of the cell
value according to our needs
a worksheet may contain thousands of
rows of data by simply examining the raw
information it would be difficult to see
patterns and Trends conditional
formatting helps us visualize data that
make worksheets easier to understand it
quickly highlights important information
in a spreadsheet by using colors icons
and data bars it changes the appearance
of one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than five thousand color the
cell yellow by applying this rule we
will be able to quickly see which cells
contain values that are greater than
5000 let us understand this with the
help of examples
consider the given sales table which
depicts the amount of sales done by each
salesman here we want to highlight the
duplicate order ID values
first select the order ID column
clip Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over highlight cells rules and select
duplicate values
a duplicate values dialog box appears
select the formatting style from the
drop down menu in our example we will
choose green fill with dark green text
click ok
here we can see that the conditional
formatting is applied to the column
order ID
Excel highlights all the duplicate cells
with green fill with dark green text
we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains
a date occurring and top slash bottom
rules
all these rules work in the similar
format
Excel provides predefined styles to
quickly apply conditional formatting to
our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph
color scales color scales change the
color of each cell based on its value
each color scale uses a two or three
color gradient icon sets icon sets add
specific icon to each cell based on its
value
let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to apply the icon set rule
if sales amount is greater than 8 000
then a green arrow should appear in the
upward Direction
if sales amount is between five thousand
and eight thousand then show a yellow
arrow in the horizontal Direction
and if sales amount is less than five
thousand then show a red arrow in the
downward Direction
to perform conditional formatting select
the desired cells
click on Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over icon set rules and select the first
rule
again click on conditional formatting
select the option manage rules from the
drop down a conditional formatting rules
manager dialog box appears
go to Icon set Rule and select three
icon set rule
click on edit Rule and an edit rule
formatting dialog box appears
by default for three icon set rule Excel
uses the 67th percentile and the 33
percentile rule this means that it shows
a green arrow for values greater than 67
percent
yellow arrows for values between 67 and
33 percent and red arrow for values less
than 33 percent
now let us customize this rule for our
criteria
in the type drop down select the option
as number
in the value reference box enter value
is 8 000 for green color arrow and 5000
for yellow color Arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color Arrow click ok
in the conditional formatting rules
manager window click ok
we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8 000
have a green arrow in the upward
Direction
values between 5K and 8K are highlighted
with a yellow arrow and values less than
5K are highlighted with a red arrow
we can also apply conditional formatting
rule with the help of formulas consider
the given table which shows the profit
done by each salesman here we want to
highlight the rows in the table wherever
profit is greater than four thousand
select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting
select the option new rule from the drop
down a new formatting rule dialog box
appears
under select rule type select the option
use a formula to determine which cells
to format
under format values reference box enter
the formula as equals if Open Bracket
dollar sign H2 greater than four
thousand comma true comma false close
bracket
this will apply formatting to a cell if
the profit is greater than four thousand
click on format button
from the format cells dialog box select
the fill tab from the color dialog box
select the color as green
finally click ok
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than four thousand are
highlighted with the green color
logical functions evaluate a cell or
cells for a criteria and returns a
Boolean value true or false
in this topic we will cover various
logical functions like if and or not
true false
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to determine the commission
percentage of each salesman
following is the criteria if net sales
greater than or equal to ten thousand
set commission as five percent
if net sales greater than or equal to
5000 and less than or equal to ten
thousand set commission as 2.5 percent
if net sales less than five thousand set
commission as one point five percent
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function
let's write the formula in cell I5 like
any other formula we will start with the
equal sign then type our function e if
and then type an open parenthesis the
first parameter we need to pass is a
logical test here The Logical test is if
sales cell G5 greater than or equal to
ten thousand assign value as five
percent
then we will pass the second logical
test here we will use and function if
Open Bracket and Open Bracket sale at
cell G5 greater than or equal to five
thousand comma cell G5 less than or
equal to ten thousand comma assign value
as 2.5 percent
in the else parameter we will type 1.5
percent this means that if the first two
cases become false then the formula will
assign the value 1.5
finally close the two braces for the two
IFS thus Excel Returns the result as 2.5
percent for cell G5
now drag the formula with the help of
the fill handle we can see the results
for the other cells as well
the or function returns true if any of
the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
in the given table we are required to
assign performance remarks for each
salesman as per the scaling table
in scaling table we have the criteria
that if net sales greater than 10 000 or
profit greater than five thousand set
remark as good
else set remark as needs Improvement
let's write the formula using IF and or
to check sales and maximum sales in cell
J5
so our formula becomes equals if Open
Bracket or Open Bracket G5 greater than
ten thousand comma H5 greater than or
equal to five thousand comma double
quote good double quote comma double
quote need Improvement double quote
close bracket
let's drag this formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
this formula returned true if any of the
condition is true thus in the given
example the cell j9 returns good even if
profit is less than five thousand
our next function is true false true
slash false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell
the not function reverses the result of
the function
if result is true it returns false else
true
let's write formula as equal not open
bracket K5 close bracket in cell L5
this Returns the result as false
let us now study about different lookup
and reference functions used in Excel
such as vlookup hlookup match index and
offset function
the vlookup function lets us search for
specific information in the current
worksheet
say we have a list of students with
marks we can search for the marks of a
specific student if our table is in
horizontal format and we want to
determine a specific value then we use
the hlookup function
consider the extract from our Master
sales table
the table depicts sales information
based on order ID Products sold salesman
and net sales now we want to determine
the net sales corresponding to order ID
let's understand how we can accomplish
this using the vlookup function
note that vlookup function is only used
for vertical tables let's use cell I2 to
add the formula
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function name
vlookup and then type and open
parentheses
now we will add the arguments the first
argument is lookup value lookup value
corresponds to the value or item we are
searching for
so in our example it will be order ID
1121 cell H2
the second argument is table array table
array is the cell range that contains
the data in this example our data is in
cell B2 to e40.
the third argument is called index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be
four
the fourth argument is range lookup this
value corresponds if we are looking for
approximate matches or not and can have
value either true or false true denotes
the approximate match and false denotes
the exact match here we will pass false
finally close the parentheses
so our function has the form equal
vlookup Open Bracket H2 comma B2 colon
E40 comma four comma false close bracket
we can see that the function Returns the
value as 2 2 7 7.
note that the vlookup function works
from left to right that means the lookup
value should always be present in the
leftmost column of our table array
if our table is in horizontal format and
we want to determine a specific value
then we use the hlookup function
consider the given table let's write the
formula in cell I4 we will start with
the equal sign then type our function
name
hlookup and then type open parentheses
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be order ID
equals one one two one
cell eight four
the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G8 to
as11.
the third argument is row index number
here our table array net sales is the
fourth row so our third argument will be
four the fourth argument is range lookup
here we will pass false finally close
the parentheses
so our function has the form equals
hlookup Open Bracket H4 comma G8 colon
as11 comma 4 comma fault close bracket
the function Returns the value to 277
note that each lookup function works
from left to right that means lookup
value should always be in the topmost
row of your table array
the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then Returns the
relative position of that item in the
array
let us understand its functioning with
the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell E5
type equal sign
then type the function name
match and then type an open parenthesis
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be date in
cell B5
the second argument is lookup array
the lookup array is a range of cells
that contains the value we are searching
for in this example we will select the
cells B17 to b1342
the third argument is match type match
type can be either -1 0 or 1. the value
should be 1. if we want to find the
largest value less than or equal to the
lookup value
the value should be zero if we want to
find the first value exactly equal to
lookup value
it should be -1 if we want to find the
smallest value greater than or equal to
lookup value
here we will pass the match type as 0 as
we require an exact match
finally close the parentheses
so our function should look like match
Open Bracket B5 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
B dollar sign one three four two comma 0
close bracket
this Returns the value as three now we
can drag the formula across cells with
the help of the fill handle
similarly we can use the match formula
in cell E3 to determine the position of
the shown field name Excel C3 in range
B17 to I17 for example net sales is at
seventh position in the range B17 to
i17. let's write the function in cell E3
write formula as equal sign match and
open parentheses in the first argument
select cell C3
for second argument select cells B17 to
I17
past third argument is zero finally
close the parentheses
so our function looks like equal match
Open Bracket C3 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
I dollar sign Seventeen comma 0 close
bracket so for profit loss field the
value returned is 8.
net sale the value returned is seven
the index function Returns value from a
specified position in a specific column
in a list
suppose we want to determine the value
of a field mentioned in cell C3 from the
sales table on a specified date
the table should dynamically fetch the
value if the value of the cell C3 is
changed
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
if we write net sales in cell C3 then
formula should fetch net sales value for
specified date
so let's use the index function to
determine the value in this worksheet
select cell C5 write formula as equal
sign index and open parentheses
the first argument is the array for our
example enter B17 colon i1342
the second argument is the row num this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter E5 which denotes the required date
the third column is column
this corresponds to the column number
that has the value we want to return
here we will enter E3 which denotes the
position of the field name in cell C3 in
table
finally close the parentheses
thus our formula Returns the value as
6528 based on the position at cells E5
this is the net sales value on the date
the 2nd of January
now drag the formula with the fill
handle to the other cells as well
the offset function returns a reference
to a range that is the offset number of
the rows and columns from another range
or cell
now let's understand how to use it
select cell D5
right formula is equal sign offset and
open parentheses the first argument is
the reference this denotes the starting
range from which the offset will be
applied for our example we will select
the reference cell as B17
the second argument is the rows this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or A negative number
so for our example we will enter E5
minus 1.
here we are subtracting 1 to match
number of row which have the value and
the offset from the reference cell
the third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name and subtract by 1 to
match with the offset referencing
finally close the parentheses
the function Returns the value based on
the position of date from cell B5 and
field from cell C3
now drag the formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
a variety of statistical functions are
available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test binomial or
chi-square
in this topic we will cover various
statistical functions like sumif
countifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and median
sumifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
sum based on one or more criteria the
sumifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain criteria
let's understand how to use the function
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table say we want to
determine the net sales done by salesman
Justin
here we will use the sumifs function to
calculate net sales so let's write the
formula in cell N4 type equal sign then
type the function name sumifs and then
type in open parentheses the first
argument is the sum range this is the
input range that contains the required
data so in our example we will select
cells H4 to H 1328
the second argument is the criteria
range this denotes the range that
contains the required criteria here we
will pass the range that holds
salesman's name cells E4 to E 1328.
the third argument is criteria this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require net sales of the salesman
Justin so we will select cell M4
finally close the parentheses note that
we can pass multiple criteria in this
function the function Returns the net
sales done by Justin
countifs function Works in a similar
manner like sumifs it counts the number
of cells in a given range when certain
criteria is met
say in the given sales table we want to
determine the total number of sales for
net sales greater than 8 000. to
determine the count we will use the
countifs function so let's write the
formula in cell N5 type the equal sign
then type the function name
countifs and then type in open
parentheses the first argument is the
criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales H4 to h1328
the second argument is criteria one this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require entries with net sales
greater than eight thousand so we will
enter greater than eight thousand
finally close the parentheses
note that the function allows you to
enter multiple criteria cell N5 reflects
the total number of sales as 445 for net
sales greater than eight thousand
in this topic we will learn how to use
the function's percentile quartile
standard deviation and median in Excel
consider the given sales table let's see
how to use the percentile function on
net sales to find its 40th percentile
select the cell n6 write the formula as
equal sign percentile Open Bracket
select the column net sales H4 to
h1328 as our first argument
pass the second argument as 0.4 in order
to find the 40th percentile
this Returns the result
5220 this means that 40 percent of the
net sales is less than or equal to 5220.
the next function is quartile
quartile function depicts the results
for the first second third and fourth
quartile
say we want to find the total number of
sales which are less than or equal to 25
percent let's use the quartile function
to calculate this
select cell N7 to write the formula
type equal sign function name is
quartile and open braces
select net sales column H4 to
h1328 as the first argument
type 1 as the second argument
the second argument must be a number
between 0 and 4. the function Returns
the value as
3822 which means that 25 percent of the
sale is less than or equal to 3822
note that here we can use the percentile
function to perform the same task the
function percentile H4 to
h1328 comma 0.25 gives us the same
result it's up to us which function we
would like to use for the quartiles
Excel has a function to calculate sample
standard deviations stdev
[Music]
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean
say we want to calculate the standard
deviation for number of customers
so write the formula in cell N8 as
equals
the function name stdev
open braces
select number of customers columns as
its argument
the function returns a result 1.4
the median function Returns the value
from the range for example we want to
find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in cell N9 write the
formula as equal sign the function name
median then open braces
select net sales column as its argument
this calculates the mid value of net
sales as 6192
rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in a
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function Returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales select cell j4
and write the formula as equal sign then
type the function name rank and then
type in open parenthesis the first
argument is the number
this is the value whose rank we are
required to calculate here we will pass
the argument cell H4
the second argument is ref
this corresponds to the array or
reference list here we will select the
column net sales IE cells H4 to H 1328.
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and 1 denotes ascending
order
this argument is optional if we don't
pass any argument Excel automatically
takes the argument zero here we will
pass zero finally close the parentheses
here we can see that Excel has
determined the rank for net sales
7164 as 553
finally we can drag the formula and can
see the rank for the other cells based
on net sales
that's it if you are an aspiring
business analyst looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learn postgraduate
program in business analysis from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be a right
choice for more details choose the link
mentioned in the description box below
so what is Excel macro you do
task and
you use data from your Excel and you
scrub data and you basically have the
same things performed or done on the
Excel sheets every time and every day or
monthly or bi-weekly or any number of
times that you open your Excel you
remove certain columns you add certain
things and you change certain values and
these are the things that you do and N
number of times on an Excel and this can
all be done by simple automated way
which is macros so what it does is it is
a set of tasks that you can execute as
many number of times as you want when
you create a macro basically what it
does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it in extract certain data and
remove certain columns that you do every
time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the absolute values of your of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
and a simple running script called
macros so what you do is you record
those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of codes or task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize whatever
click customize ribbon and then there is
a developer tab which you see here it
should be activated so you just need to
select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macros now you you
have your data and you can run macros or
record a macro and run it all on your
Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing
so here I have a work orders sheet that
I receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do and you know this report has so
many things that are obsolete which you
do not need which has to be put across
to your management or your for your use
so how you record or start a macro you
go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record macro button it will
start recording your keystrokes on the
mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro so when I click record
macro it starts uh recording my mouse
clicks and keystrokes so in this sheet I
have to you know remove some columns and
the columns that are Obsolete and the
data that looks weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the work
order number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the requested
workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work
order
accounts
and I'll add a little description like
work order
counts deep
costs
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the laborers the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts team I do not
want any of these obsolete data
so I just delete this okay and then I
just want to have some cosmetic changes
done so
I make sure this doesn't have any border
and that's it this is the task that I
perform
everyday okay still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro C which we ran the just
now and I simple with a single click I
will be able to do these daily tasks and
execute in a Flash so I just click run
and it does the rest for me I have my
report ready and is in a proper format
that is required and it can be sent
across so here as we see it is done in a
single click by running a simple macro
continuing our uh to work on macro we
can simply do this by a single click of
a button by adding a button so what you
have to do is go to the developer tab
and in the control section you will see
the insert option option when you click
on the insert drop down you will see a
form controls and you can say select a
button and here I select a button and
the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
making it as a work order accounts just
to make it simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in a
single click of button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros and instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same function that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
VBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro go to the developer tab and
then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here
so as we see if you go back to the Excel
we see that I received we have been
working on the sheet and it has the
column still K and the actual sheet is
this so if I go to the Visual Basic
editor
and I'll make sure you know I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m and I just delete that
and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA
so here we are what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our TDS daily task by running a simple
macro now to help us you know write
these macros and help us get the best
use of our abilities to ease our work
and automate our task we use VBA
so
why we be there are many advantages of
using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel so basically it is a
very simple language it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous section how we
you can simplify your daily task by just
running a simple macro and this VBA
helps us in performing those tasks in a
very simple manner another thing is it
supports english-like statements there
are multiple statements that you can use
and which are very basic English
language statements and this can help us
or it is very easy to program our code
or edit these commands you can select a
range you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we will
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the VBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail where where you can edit your
commands or your codes for your Excel
now how this is achieved we will see it
here now these are the this is basically
the VBA editor interface where you can
see the uh this is the toolbar section
where it shows all the options wherein
undo or save or file they will see those
details in the next section this is
basically the toolbar section of the VBA
editor interface the next thing is the
menu bar menu bar as we all know it is
simply it shows you the menu wherein you
have all the options like file edit view
insert insert is the one very important
menu bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window maybe a
code window as it says is the code
window where your actual code resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the course and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
bdb VBA code window where you editor or
write your codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the the Excel sheets or
the worksheets that you're working on or
the modules that you have saved and so
on basically it is an Explorer for your
PBA like a Windows Explorer which is for
the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties Windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet2 and it shows the
properties what are the kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window where then you can run and
execute simple lines of course
individual Excel code that you can run
it will allow you to test individual
lines
which is very useful and handy when
you're writing and debugging course uh
the output if the lines that you execute
can be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the U the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
um Visual Basic for application window
or alternatively you can just go and
click on the Visual Basic and it will
open the sheet video I mean the code
window for you and as we have discussed
before these are the windows that we see
this is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
you can run some testing codes
immediately it will show you the code so
here we see the project Explorer window
where we see the modules and all for our
Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and
the columns
[Music]
desperate but can I just save it click
okay and it has started recording so now
what I'll do is as make it simple and I
just delete some columns here
okay I do not need this I delete this is
there a wait I want this I want the mode
of payment parts cost labor hours I do
not want this some Reflections forget it
okay
and I go for the left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to time stream
okay
I'm going to go back to my developer tab
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
uh in detail what it looks like so we
see the code what it's doing and what
the macro run has generated the codebook
so we see we have basically the name of
the macro is format columns and what it
is doing we're just selecting The
Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
VB and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank spreadsheet and I'll try to
explain some basic
functions and the commands and the
quotes that we use to accomplish the
task that we with VBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as it says
it starts with sub and I am specifying
the
module name as a number so I'll just try
to make it quite simple and
you know so we as as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the how do the macro now uh I'll
explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what is it
used for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompts so I select
integer and for example I select the
number to be
500. okay and here I'm trying to assign
a variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limp keyword
so where exactly I want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay range I am selecting it should be
under course where I'm going to put the
value of x as and I close the bracket
and what should be the value
we will value should be X so now as I
click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt F5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain more example some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as
double
when double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses needs more larger numbers
okay and then you can set
double and I just uh Chrome specified
and we can use date so it basically
stores the date values okay and then
again string so what string does if you
use string it stores the text it can
contain numbers it will have some text
as calculations or anything can be
performed so these are the basic thing
that I will cover and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
so in the next example I'll try to
use a string value for it and
value
[Music]
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I can get my code so I put it as
name book it has
okay
okay now
I'm trying to use uh
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select Mac
[Music]
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and four
so I close it
and I put a value what value I am going
to assign it is a country
try to run this code right
and see G4 the name populates as a
country here so this is a dim keyword is
being used as a string in our VBA code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be executed
using a
code here which I am going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
I'm going to name it as double value and
again the main keyword I'm going to use
the
keyword as double
app y double is used is basically it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable text it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now I'm going to pop up a message in
this which says value of a is so and so
so I'm going to give value of a as
250 okay and how I it pops up a message
okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you you can enter
the text and you can edit Library so
here I'm going to
write a code which you know which gives
a pop-up message a message box saying
that the value of a is signed so
I'm going to put it in and percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay now that's it and let's try to run
this and you will see a message for
popping message box popping up
okay so the value of e is the message
box
pops up saying the value of a is 250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it has
run with some procedures but
name
again name
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give any I mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
okay
of course
this is the
the report
let's make it simple
okay
and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report for VBA so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I am going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
pitch displays here name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name is it fun so this is a message box
that you can display and I can do
anything with this
oh
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of data in it and these
can be used using run using the message
box
and now I have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
I'll put it as sub
okay
and
it will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
and entered
value
is
and it should tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I give a range
[Music]
code completed
just tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
E1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
4.
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a
let me show you one more simple example
where in a message box pops up or a
welcome message that can be power set
when you open the Excel or worksheet so
so let's uh
name it as Auto
open
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and what does it say
codes will come
to power
or shift
um Workshop
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to a simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
pairing you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
good
so we name it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I
am going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
[Music]
I'm going to
give it as B5
okay to put it as close the parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to be 10.
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean okay let me make
it very simple here
I give it as a B1
through b
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I am going I am specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay and
then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
means to be
[Music]
c one
I
have to give it a course
give me an error
error
C4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis I ordered the value that I
give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 has been
specified in the code
so this is one of one more example
wherein you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
[Music]
seven
and if I close the parenthesis I assign
a value to it value equals
10. let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and column seven
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in a sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using BPA so I will show you
how
this is our
let's say select the
range
okay and
and I am going to set a dim variable as
an example okay let's say it has example
and um what I'm doing is I'm specific
range because I need to select a range
of itself okay now I'm going to set the
variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a 1 t
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and give a give a value to it
so you can do it with the click of a
button with a VPN
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value I'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then you see it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or sales with these
groups
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set up another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay
worksheets I want it in sheet 2 okay so
I just put it a C2 and I activated
basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
2 and what is the range that I'm going
to select the same thing okay
A1
to D Phi
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet two
as I'm activating it and I'm going to
assign range and I am going to select it
so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that is again a
simple code that you can write and let's
say
let's say it has a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
relate and
copy
okay so what I'm going to do is I am
going to select this range and I'm going
to copy it and paste it somewhere here
okay so let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes
[Music]
of course
and I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is uh once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet
and paste it so we are selecting a range
of cells selection and that selection
what we are doing is we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to
select it and then paste it
quite simple
let's
okay
and
just change it to so it is visible on
this
important
okay
so this makes uh quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to get the count of the
number of cells like you have to have a
selection and you need to count the
number of cells so this can also be done
and it's quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the sub B account
sets
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you are using it and
I'm going to set a variable let's say
I'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as I read and then
what we are going to do is
example
and we'll specify the range here
you can specify the range or your
selection where you will count the where
you need the count of the number of
cells so even
if the high hopes
this is n now how you want the output
you want it you want a message box to
pop up
so you will set up
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay
let's see it says
okay here typing and listed so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
count in this or 20 okay
now let's see I'm going to six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and wherein you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the county number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
here see it gives there are five columns
okay one two
one two three four five okay so it gives
us the number of columns here if I
change it to should give me
for forever okay similarly you can count
the number of rows here
foreign
okay
should give me another
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
one whoever is in programming I'm very
much familiar with this function so what
it does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the outshoot
output should be such instead we can
specify the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
if it is achieved then you will have to
specify the output as well so this can
be achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so it's not very complicated
and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result port
so this is one thing and then you can
specify the s or else condition where
you know you specify the condition 2
then the result should be
this
so here you are going to
specify two conditions or multiple
conditions where you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Max
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
okay
let's
specify as
if
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have two variables I have a score
and I have a result and the score is an
integer the number and the result is a
string pass of a so I specify this okay
dim
score
as specified as integer okay
and then
there's another variable that I have to
set result
as string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
score I am giving it as a range admin
at 10 9
.
9 cell A1
okay
I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
should be erupt
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
core value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
and codes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay and now
where I want to specify my result I
should give a range for that as well
as well so I give it in the next column
or any one
this is the basic example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
Express
change it to 40.
foreign
because I have specified only one
condition here okay
I'm 75 let's see how it turns
see so this way it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifically
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and C so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's uh stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
here else
the result should be
okay
and now I have to put it as a and if
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be V1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
I think this path let's see
run it again
it's okay so we are specifying two
variables again we are giving a Terrain
and we are specifying one condition if
this condition is met the result is
passed otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
the next statement that we use or we're
going to discuss is the Loop statement
that is the for Loop statement and why
we use it there are there are situations
and uh tasks that you need to execute
and you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first treatment or the function
is executed and the next is taken up so
and then the next and so on so these
Loop statements allow us to execute a
statement or a group of statements
multiple number of times many number of
times and this happens only when the
first task or the first task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we'll discuss a simple
example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one so here it is I
have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 2
.4 okay
let's see
range as so what I'm going to do is
basically I'm going to fill the column A
from 1 to 24 with some value from 1 to
24 that's the values of 1
okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
one I'll explain you have it so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up an
integer a variable X as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1 and it fills
in A1 and then the next value of x will
be 2 and it goes to A2 and fills the
value as 2 so just let's try to execute
this and you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is 1 to be 24.
okay so this is one basic example of a
purloop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
sector for Loop and giving the output
and we'll code the output to be the
color code advance in the column B so
how we do it it's a basic simple example
that I'm going to take and again what
I'm going to do is I will have this
values here and I am going to calculate
the
V column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
and
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is if you select it
and it should color the interior with
what
is the color index okay
foreign
X
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the box to be colored and I'm going to
put it as a solid
it will fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
LV
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
you can perform tasks we can perform
with the BBA and this can be found in
detail
and then exclusive Advanced courses
that's it if you are an aspiring
business analyst looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learn postgraduate
program in business analysis from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft should be a right
choice for more details choose the link
mentioned in the description box below
So currently I am on my MySQL workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so I'll give my password
and click on OK
all right so this is my MySQL workbench
query editor so first we are going to
learn sub queries let me give a comment
and write sub queries
all right so first of all let's
understand what a sub query is so a sub
query is a query within another SQL
query that is embedded within the where
Clause from clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that I'll
be using my
database that is SQL underscore intro so
I'll write my command use SQL underscore
intro
now this database has a lot of tables
I'll be using the employees table that
is present inside SQL underscore intro
Let me just expand this and you can see
here we have an employee's table
so let me first show you
the contents within this table I'll
write select star from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee ID employee name each gender
there's data join Department City and
salary and we have information for 20
employees if I scroll down you can see
there are 20 employees present in our
table
so let's say you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
the average salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query so let me show you how to write a
sub query
I'll write the select statement
in the select statement I'll pass
my column names that I want to display
so the column names I want are the
employee name
that I want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next I'll use a where condition where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees so
I'll write salary greater than
after this I am going to write my sub
query
so I'll give select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees
and I'll close the bracket and give a
semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once you get the average salary number
we'll use this where condition where
salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if I run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is 75 350 dollars
now I want to display all the employees
who have salary greater than 75
350 dollars so let's run our sub query
there you go so there are eight
employees in our table who have a salary
greater than the average salary of all
the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
John's salary
so we have one employee whose name is
John
let me
run the table once again
okay if I scroll down
you see we have an employee
as John
you see this
our employee ID 116 is John and his
salary is sixty seven thousand dollars I
want to display all the employees whose
salary is greater than John's salary so
basically all the employees who are
earning more than 65 000 I want to print
them
so let's see how to do it
I'll write
select
I want the employee name comma the
gender of the employee
I also want the department and salary
from my table name that is employees
I'll write where
salary is greater than
I'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket I am
going to give my inner query that is
Select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is John
So within single quotations I'll give
John as my employee
I'll end with a semicolon
so let me first run my inner query
so this will give us this salary that
John has which is sixty seven thousand
dollars now I want the employees who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see
12 rows returned which means there are
12 employees in our table who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars you see here all these employees
have a salary greater than sixty seven
thousand dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic Model so I'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website I'll just show you the
website so this is the website that is
MySQL tutorial.org
you can see here they have very nice
articles blogs from where you can learn
MySQL in detail so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website you see here
they have a MySQL sample database if you
click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
MySQL sample database and the name of
the database is classic models all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session
if I expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have qriket
customers as employees office this
orders order lines and many more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and product
stable first let me show you the content
that is present inside
the products table first
if I run this
you see here it says 110 rows return
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock Buy price
MSRP
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the details of
all the orders
let me show you
the records
or a details tables has okay so there
are thousand records present in this
table you have the order number the
product code quantity ordered price of
each item you have the order line number
as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products whose price of each product is
less than hundred dollars for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables and we are going to
write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here in the order details
table we have a column called price each
I want to display the product code the
product name and the MSRP of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way I'm going to do is
I'll write select
product code comma
product name
now one thing to remember
this product name is actually present
inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is production order details
here you can see this is the product
code column
comma MSRP which is present inside the
products table again
from my table that is
products
where
I'll write
product
code
I'm going to use the in operator
next I'll write my inner query that is
Select
product code
from my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than 100 dollars
let me run this
okay so you can see there are total 83
products in our table which have
a price less than hundred dollars you
can see the
price here
okay
now we learn another Advanced Concept in
SQL which is known as stored procedures
I'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an SQL code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again save it as a stored procedure
and then call it to execute it
so in this example I want to create a
stored procedure that will return the
list of players who have scored more
than six goals in a tournament
so I have a database called SQL
underscore IQ
these are a few databases that I've
already created so this database has a
table called players if I expand the
tables
option you see we have a table called
players and you can see the columns
player ID the name of the player the
country to which the player belongs to
and the number of goals each player has
scored in a particular tournament so
I'll write a stored procedure that will
return the list of top players who have
scored more than 6 goals in a tournament
so first of all let me Begin by
using MySQL underscore IQ database
will run it
so now we are inside the SQL underscore
IQ database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are six players in our
table
we have the player ID
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so I'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this it should start with
a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter I'll write
ambition ampersand
next I'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name
let's say amount to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin I'll write my select
statement
I want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from my table that is
players
where
I'll write goals is greater than
6.
we'll give a semicolon
then
I'll end my
procedure with a delimiter that was
double ambison
next
I'll write delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space okay
now let's run our
stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our store procedure now the way
to run a stored procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals and not
goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll edit here as well
now let's create it again
okay
now to
call my procedure I'll write call space
followed by the procedure name which is
top underscore players
if I run this you can see we have two
players in our table who have scored
more than six goals so we consider them
as the top players in a particular
tournament
all right
now there are other methods that you can
use while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so I'll give a comment
stored procedure using in parameter
all right
so for this example I'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees based on their
salaries
so if you have a table
in our SQL underscore IQ database which
is called employee details
I am going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of joint City
and salary
using this table I'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and we'll use the in parameter so let me
show you how to do it
I'll write
delimiter this time I am going to use
forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
SP for stored procedure
sort by
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure I'll give my
parameter
in
I'll create a variable bar and assign a
data type integer
then I'll write begin
followed by my select statement but I'll
select the name
each
salary
from
my table name that is
EMP details or employee details
I am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
I want to display
limited number of
records so I'm using this
limit keyword and my variable VAR which
I
created here
I learned my select statement
I'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and I'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not here
you have an option to see the stored
procedures let me just refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our store procedure I'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by salary
and inside this I'll give my parameter
which was actually VAR and this VAR
we have used in limit
let's say I want to display only the top
three records of the employees who have
the top three highest salaries
okay so let me run it
there you go so Ami Sarah and Jimmy but
the top three employees who have the
highest salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement and we
called our stored procedure and passed
in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select statement inside
stored procedure you can also use other
statements let's say update
so I'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of Select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the in
operator twice so let me show you how to
do it
I'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be forward slash then I'll
write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the
update salary name
I'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
I'll assign is worker 20
I'll again use my in parameter I'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
I'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement I'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and I'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure if I refresh this
you can see I have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's see
first of all I'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table okay
so we have six rows of information let's
say you want to update the salary of
employee Jimmy or let's say
Mary
from 70 000 to let's say 72 000.
or let's say eighty thousand so I'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time I'm going to pass in two
parameters the first parameter will be
the employee name and next with a comma
I'll give my new salary that I want to
so my employee name let's say is Mary
and the salary I want
to be updated is let's say eighty
thousand dollars
I'll give a semicolon
and I'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go if you see this record for
maybe we have successfully updated the
salary to eighty thousand dollars
now moving ahead
we learned to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter so I'll give a
comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
will create total employees as an output
parameter and the data type would be an
integer the count of the female
employees is assigned to the output
variable which is total underscore emps
using the into keyword let me show you
how to write a stored procedure using
the out parameter
so first I'll declare my delimiter
to forward slash
I'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be SP underscore
count
employees
and inside this I am going to give my
out parameter and the variable name that
is total underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next I am going to write begin
followed by my select statement that is
Select
I want the
count of total employees
and the output I am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is EMP underscore
details
where
sex is equal to
F which means female
I'll go by semicolon
next I'll end it
with the TV limiter and I am going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is colon
so let me tell you what I am doing here
I am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure I am going
to count the total number of female
employees that are present in our table
EMP underscore details so I've used my
out parameter and I am creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer
here in the select statement I'm
counting the names of the employees and
the result I am storing it in total
underscore emps
I have used my wear condition where the
gender of the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure let's refresh this
okay you can see we have a new stored
procedure SP underscore count employees
now
call it I'll write call
the name of the procedure that is Count
underscore SP underscore count
employees
within brackets I'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
F underscore EMP
will give a semicolon then I'll write
select
at the rate F underscore
EMP as female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first I'll
call my procedure and then we'll display
the total number of female employees you
can see in our table we have three
female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next Topic in this
tutorial on Advanced SQL now we are
going to learn about triggers in SQL
so I'll give a
comment here
reverse in SQL
so first let's understand what is a
trigger so a trigger is a special type
of stored procedure that runs
automatically when an event occurs in
the database server there are mainly
three types of triggers in SQL we have
the data manipulation trigger we have
the data definition trigger and login
triggers
in this example we will learn how to use
a before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the students rule
number the age the name and the students
marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than 0 a
trigger will automatically set the marks
to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students
all right
so I'll write
create
table
student
foreign
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or bearing character
size I'm giving it as 30 finally we have
the marks as floating type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table
now
I'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time I'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is Mark
underscore
let's say verify
I am going to use a before insert
trigger so I'll write before insert
on my table name that is student
next I'll write for each row
if
new DOT
marks
is less than zero
then
will set
new DOT
marks
equal to 50.
so this is my
condition first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0 we'll assign a value
50 to that student because usually the
marks are not less than 0 in any exam
I'll write end if
semicolon and I'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command I'll run it
it says trigger already exists so in
this case we need to update the
trigger name let's say
I'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for St
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is Mark and
not marks so here we need to change it
as Mark instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so I'll write insert into student
I'll write
values
and get the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10 the name is it's a
root
and the marks is let's say 75 point
zero
give a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student rule number is 502
age is 12
the name is let's say Mike
and this time I'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the Third
record
for student rule number 503
age is 13
the name is Dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by Dave is
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
these is 10
name I'll enter as Jacobs
and this time again I'm purposely giving
the marks in negative
12 point let's say 5.
close the bracket and give a semicolon
and I'll run my insert statement okay so
we have inserted four rows of
information to our student table
now
let me run the select query I'll write
select star from student
if I run this you see the difference
there you go
so originally we had inserted
for 502 the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504 for Jacobs the marks
was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because
when we created our trigger we had set
our marks to 50 in case the marks were
less than zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name in this case our
trigger name is
Max underscore big Pi underscore St
I'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
you give this as a comment okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial Concept in SQL which is very
widely used
this is known as views so views are
actually virtual tables that do not
store any data of their own but display
data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
I'll give a comment as views in SQL
okay
now to learn views I am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as I mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so I'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so I'll write select
star from customers
okay I missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name customer number we
have the address State country and other
information
now I'll write a basic view command
using this customer table the way to
write is I'll write create
View
followed by The View name which is cast
underscore details
then you write as
select
I am going to select a few column names
from my original customer table which is
this one so I need the customer name
let's say I need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number
and the City
all right
I'll write from my table that is
customers
if I run this
my view the discussed details will be
created
let's run it there's some error here
because the name of the table is
customers and not customer
I'll give an S and I'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and
to display the contents that are present
inside our view I can write select star
from followed by The View name that is
cast underscore details
foreign
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name
the phone number and the City of the
different customers that we have in our
table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that I am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table I'm talking about the products
table and the product lines table
present inside classic models database
so before I start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description and there's some HTML
description and image
so
I'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing create
View
followed by The View name that is
product underscore
description
as I'll write
select
product
name
comma
then I'll write
quantity
in stock
I also want the MSRP
now these three columns are present
inside the products table and next from
the
product line stable I want the text
description
of the products
so I'll write from
product stable
I'll give an alias as p
followed by Inner join my other table
that is
product lines as let's say PL
on
the common column that is product line
so P Dot
product line
is equal to
I'll give a space
PL Dot product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description let us run it all right so
we have our view ready
now let me
View
or display what is present inside our
product underscore description
View
I'll add select star from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock msrpn textual
descriptions of the different products
in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view instead of product
underscore description you want to give
some other name
so I'll just give a comment rename
description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement I'll write rename table
product
underscore description Which is my
old name
I want to change this name to let's say
I'll give vehicle description
since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so I'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see I have
renewed my
View
so here if I just refresh it and I'll
expand this you can see we have the cast
details view and we have the vehicle
underscore description View
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
I'll write display views
is the comment
now to show all the views you can use so
full tables
where
table
underscore
type is equal to within single quote
I'll write View
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error this
should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so I'll write drop
view followed by The View name let's say
I want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view
I'll write drop View cast underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cast underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about Windows functions
now Windows functions were Incorporated
in MySQL in the 8.0 version
so Windows function in MySQL are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my SQL underscore intro
database
so we'll find the total combined salary
of the employees for each department
so first let me switch my database to
SQL underscore
into database
I'll run it okay
I'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we'll partition our table by department
and print the total salary and this we
are going to do using
some windows functions in MySQL
so I'll write
select
I want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next I'll write
this sum of salary
over
I want to partition it by
Department
so I'll write Partition by Department
which is Dept
and I'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go so here we have created
another column in our result that is
total salary and for each of the
employees and the respective departments
you have the highest salary so in
finance the highest salary of one of the
employees was
155 000 dollars
similarly if I come down we have the
highest salary from HR if I scroll
further we have the highest salary from
it marketing product sales and the tech
team
all right
now we'll explore a function which is
called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function I'll write
select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so I'll write order by salary
I'll give the
Alias as row num
give a comma
and I want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees and I'll
order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a ronum column and we have
successfully given row numbers to each
of the records you can see it starts
from one and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first I'll create a table
I'll write create table
let's say I'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's see we have in this table the
student ID which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type worker
the size is 20. I'll create the small
table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so I'll write insert
into
demo
values
I'll give 101
the name is
Shane
give a comma
I'll insert the second student name 102
the name is
Bradley
you give a comma
this time
for 1 0 3 we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
hirath
you give a comma I'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated one zero three
next we have one zero four
the name of the student that says
Nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student which is Kevin we have
two records
I'll copy this
and I'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you I'll write select
star from demo
if you see this we have a few
information that are duplicated in our
table
that is for student id103 and student ID
105.
now I am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table I'll write
select student underscore ID comma
student underscore name
I'll give another comma and write
row underscore number
over
within brackets
I'll write partition
by
St underscore ID
comma
St underscore name
okay
then I'll write
order by St underscore ID
close the bracket I'll give an alias as
ronum
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right if you see here there is just
one student in the name Shane we have
one student in the name Bradley but here
if you see for herath
the second record it says to which means
there are two records for hirath and if
I scroll down there is one record for
Nathan and there are two records for
Kevin which means Kevin is also repeated
okay
now we are going to see another Windows
function that is called rank function
in MySQL so the rank function assigns a
rank to a particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
rank values when two or more rows have
the same rank so first of all let me
create a table
and the name of the table would be a
random name will give it as let's say
demo one
and it will have only one
column let's say variable a of type
integer
we'll create this table first okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table which is demo one so I'll write
value
one zero one
zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
I'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
we have one zero four
one zero five
we have one zero six
and let's say 106 is also repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay
let me insert these values to my table
that is demo one okay this is done
now
if I write
select
VAR underscore a
and use my rank function I'll write rank
over
then I'll
order by my variable that is VAR
underscore e
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo one
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if I run this there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test tank is 2 but
for this value which is 1 0 3 the test
rank is repeated because there was a
repetition for one zero three
so we have skipped the rank 4 here for
104 the rank is 5 now for one zero five
the rank is 6 now
106 again since the record was repeated
twice we have skipped the eighth Rank
and
our rank function assigned the same
value which is seven for one zero six
and for the last value 107 the rank is
9.
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final Windows function which is
called first value
so first value is another important
function in MySQL so this function
Returns the value of the specified
expression with respect to the first row
in the window frame
all right
so what I'm going to do is
I am going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and I'll write
first underscore
value which is my function and pass in
my employee name
and then I'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
I'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is employees
so let me run this and see how the
first underscore value function works
all right so in our table
Joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
I'll write select EMP underscore name
comma
I want the department
and the salary
comma
I'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
I'll write over
here I am going to use partition
I am going to partition it by
department since I want to know the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department
and I am going to order by
salary
descending
and I'll give my Alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's run this and see the difference
in the output okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for freelance
Jack had the highest salary from HR it
was Marcus similarly in it it was
William
if I scroll down for marketing it was
John a product it was Alice who had the
highest salary similarly in sales we had
Joseph
and in Tech we had Angela
so this is how you can use the first
underscore value function using
partition
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on our tutorial
so let me just scroll through and show
you what we did from the beginning first
we learned about sub queries in SQL so
we initially wrote a simple sub query
and then we used our classic models
database which was downloaded from the
internet and also shown you the link
from where you can download this
database here we used two different
tables and we performed a sub query
operation
we learned how to create stored
procedures
so we learned how you can use the in
operator or the in parameter as well as
the out parameter in stored procedure
after stored procedure we learned
another crucial Concept in SQL which is
called triggers now triggers are also
special kind of stored procedures so we
saw how to write a before insert trigger
you can see it here
next
we learned how to delete a trigger we
also saw how to work with views in SQL
so views are basically virtual tables
that you can create from existing tables
we also saw how you can use views using
two different tables and an inner join
and
we learned how to display views how to
rename
view names
how to delete a view and finally we
explored a few Windows function
that's it if you are an aspiring
business analyst looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in business
analysis from Purdue University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft should be a right choice for
more details choose the link mentioned
in the description box below Apex is a
journey that involves a combination of
skills
advances locations and processes used by
a firm gain business insights from data
and statistics
this is done to perform business
planning
in the analytics process data is
collected from various external sources
and is stored in a data warehouse
after this data collection the process
of analytics begins
here a more in-depth learning of the
data is done to derive possible insights
from data
in addition to this all advanced
data-driven capabilities are developed
which in turn provides additional value
to business
in the next slide we will look at the
places where analytics is applied
of the common fields where analytics is
implemented are as follows
Financial Services
in this field analytics is used for
credit scoring fraud detection pricing
and claims analysis
in retail it is used for promotions
replenishment demand forecasting and
Merchandising optimization
in healthcare it is used for drug
interaction
preliminary diagnosis and disease
management
customer retention capacity planning and
network optimization are the primary
applications in the field of
communications
trading Supply demand forecasting and
compliance are the areas of application
in energy
in manufacturing it is used for
inventory replenishment
product customization and supply chain
optimization
in the next slide we will look at the
topics that are covered in the first and
second lessons
in lesson one you will learn what
analytics is and understand the process
involved in it
the lesson will also provide brief
details on where you can apply analytics
and what insights can be derived from
this application
this helps you in understanding a
problem and knowing how a data scientist
should act
this lesson will also help you in
knowing how to collect data and prepare
it for your analytical process
in the second lesson you will have an
overview of all statistical methods
including descriptive statistics
probability Theory concepts of test of
significance and hypothesis testing
some business uses of these statistical
Concepts have also been provided via
case studies for better understanding
this lesson will give you an idea of how
you can derive some meaningful pattern
from the data
it will help you in finding the
distribution pattern that is hidden in
the data and in proceeding with further
decisions that are to be made at the
basic level
in the next slide we will look at the
topics that will be covered in the third
and fourth lessons
third lesson will help you understand
data exploration data visualization and
diagnostic analytics and perform these
using the r tool
case studies and examples have been
provided to help you understand the
concepts in a practical way and also
help you use the r tool effectively
the fourth lesson will help you
understand some predictive techniques
such as regression analysis and models
that could be built from them
logistic regression time series analysis
and cluster analysis will also be taught
with some example case studies
these predictive modeling techniques
will help you look at the past data and
identify the predicted value that helps
in making decisions
further all the working procedures are
explained using the r tool in a stepwise
manner with suitable examples
in the next slide we will look at the
career path of a business analyst
the of analytics has evolved over time
and the Advent of big data has made
analytics one of the most sought after
skills in the industry across domains
this course will help you take the first
step toward understanding analytics and
the way it interfaces with the industry
the course will also help you start
thinking like a business analyst
career-wise you can aspire to be a data
manager data Miner or a business manager
the work of a data manager involves
data preparation
deployment Services report
Administration
the work of a data Miner involves
exploratory analysis
descriptive segmentation
predictive modeling
the work of a business manager involves
campaign management
domain expertise
process and Roi evaluation
this includes Lesson Zero of the
business analytication with our tools
course offered by implalern thank you
for your attention
please continue your learning with
lesson one of this course
hello and welcome to one of the business
analytics foundation with our tools
course offered by simply learn
after completing this course you will be
able to differentiate between analysis
and analytics understand what is
analytics learn the different stages in
Analytics
know the popular tools used in Analytics
understand the role of a data scientist
no the process is involved in analytics
Define a problem statement
collect and summarize data detect and
treat outliers in the data
we all know we are learning about
analytics then what is analysis is it by
any means different from analytics if
yes in what ways is it different in this
slide we see the basic difference
between analytics and Analysis
analytics is the science of analysis
wherein we apply methods of Statistics
Data Mining and computer technology for
doing an analysis
whereas analysis is the process in which
the complex data available has been
broken down to simpler forms which
provide more Compact and better data for
understanding
in the next slide we will see more into
what is Analytics
so what actually is analytics it's the
science of wisely acquiring meaningful
results from the given data using
various methods and Technologies and by
which a pattern of variation is observed
by studying this pattern we can
understand the future and predict the
uncertainty that is related to business
various sophisticated models and
techniques are used like statistical
mathematical and economical models
so how do you go about analytics
first you gather data for example for a
commercial entity you collect data from
Enterprise social media internet forums
Etc
second you Club all the data together
and consolidate and organize it in a
form from which you can analyze through
visualization statistics
Etc which is the third step in the
process
in the next slide we will see the
different stages of Analytics
there are major four stages in any
analytics work
the first stage is called descriptive
analytics where data or information is
gathered and summarized this stage
usually caters to questions like how
many students dropped out last year
the next stage is called diagnostic
analytics where data is analyzed and
insights are generated
which help in answering the questions in
the first stage
here the question that comes up will be
why has the dropout rate increased in
the last one year
with the help of the analysis done in
the previous two stages the next stage
tries to answer unforeseen phenomena
like which students are most likely to
drop out this stage is called Predictive
Analytics
finally the last stage known as
prescriptive analytics tries to analyze
the type of action required to be taken
to support or avoid the unforeseen
phenomena predicted in the previous
stage in this scenario prescriptive
analytics has queries like which
students should I Target to keep them
from dropping out
next we will look at a list of a few
popular tools used in Analytics
these are some of the commonly used
tools for analytical purpose to get
meaningful results
are
Revolution r
Studio
tableau
sap Hana
wakea
kxen
SAS
next we will discuss the role of a data
scientist
so what is the role of a data scientist
in data analytics
a data scientist is somebody who is
inquisitive who can look at data and
spot Trends they come out with
unrevealed stories hidden in data that
helps in creating more useful insights
and thus help in solving business
problems
a data scientist Works in sync with
application developer to get the
relevant data for analysis
he or she makes an analytical plan in
such a way that the results satisfy the
business needs
a data scientist also comes up with an
effective data mining architecture and
prepares suitable models they are
responsible for resolving data mining
performance issues and finally they
should generate reports that are
affordable from a business perspective
next we will see the methodology
involved in data analytics the data
analytics methodology comprises of six
steps as can be seen in the image
the discovery step is questioning if
there is sufficient data to make an
analytical plan once we have the data in
data preparation all unstructured data
is converted into structured data so
that it helps in planning
model planning is choosing an
appropriate model that suits your data
model building is building the model
that is being specified in the previous
step the next step is to come up with
insights that help customers to solve
their problems that is to deliver
results
the final step is to make the model
operational and put the findings to use
next we will discuss how to define the
problem
defining the problem statement is an
important step in analytics and needs to
be done before starting the project at a
high level the problem statement should
answer four basic questions
what is the problem find the existing
problem that needs to be solved
what is it not Define the problem that
is not being caused
why do we have this problem find the
root cause of the problem
why don't we have a solution this gives
the answer that is why the problem could
not be resolved
in the next slide we will discuss how to
formally Define a problem statement the
techniques that are involved in formally
defining a problem are State the problem
in a general way that is State the
problem in general terms with respect to
some practical scientific or
intellectual interest
the next step is to understand the
nature and origin of the problem its
objectives and the environment in which
the problem is to be studied
next all available literature including
relevant theories reports records and
any form of relevant literature on the
problem needs to be reviewed and
examined
the next step is optional the researcher
may discuss the problem with his or her
colleagues and others related to the
concerned subject to brainstorm ideas
finally rephrase the problem that is put
the problem in specific terms that make
it feasible and helps in the development
of working hypotheses
next we will look at ways to summarize
data
before summarizing data the types of
data need to be discussed data can be
two types
qualitative or quantitative qualitative
or categorical data refers to data that
are descriptive they are generally
recorded in groups or in descriptive
language example dividing people into
high medium and low height groups
quantitative or numeric data refers to
data that are recorded in numbers they
could be either continuous or discrete
variables example the measured height of
a person
in the next slide we will discuss how to
analyze this data
summarizing refers to procedures that
are applied on the raw data to convert
them into an easily readable and
analyzable format the mathematical
summaries differ according to the type
of data numerical or categorical and
fall into descriptive and graphical
categories
seen here is an example of population
divided by marital status a bar chart
has been used to depict the same data in
the next slide we will see the different
summaries based on the categories
numeric data can be summarized using the
mean median and mode values
these are discussed in detail in the
following chapters along with other
methods for summarizing
categorical data can be summarized using
a frequency distribution table that is
the number of occurrences of a value for
all values graphical representations
help in Easy visualization of the data
numeric variables can be viewed as box
plots and the categorical variables can
be viewed in bar charts or histograms
the visualizations will be discussed in
detail in the following chapters
in the next slide we will discuss how to
collect data
data collection is the process of
gathering data that is relevant to the
problem statement at hand
the data AIDS improving or disproving
hypotheses or provide solutions to a
research or a problem statement
regardless of the problem the data
collection process needs to be well
defined and systematic
in an effort to construct accurate data
the accuracy of the data is the primary
factor in deciding the validity of the
findings
depending on the method used to collect
data the observations need to be
recorded and organized in such a way to
provide Optimum usefulness
the recording and organization of data
must also be directly related to the
methods of analysis and use of the data
we will see the methods of collecting
data in the next slide
the data collection methods fall into
two major categories
primary and secondary
observations experiments and surveys
fall into the primary category
observations refer to measuring the data
and various attributes in experiments
the subjects are divided into groups
receive different external input and the
results are recorded
surveys questionnaires and interviews
help in recording feedback and are used
in studying the characteristics of a
population
data sources refer to data that have
already been gathered and are available
in a published format reporting refers
to cases where there exists a database
of information that can be legally
obtained
next we will discuss data dictionary
a data dictionary also called a metadata
repository is a file that describes the
structure and content of the data
the data dictionary is a file or a list
of files that contains data about the
database like
number of Records name of each field
characteristic and type of each field
description of each field relationships
between different fields
in analysis the data dictionary helps in
analyzing different variables and the
relationships and dependencies between
each other
in the next slide we will discuss the
final topic of this lesson outliers
outliers are observation points in
addition
deviates from other observations if you
look at the graph it plots the marks
obtained as a result of a particular
study time the trend is that marks
increase as the students study longer
except for one marked point this could
be a possible outlier outliers could
exist in a distribution due to erroneous
observations or special circumstances
like a bulk sales order on a particular
day in a store
outlier detection tests exist to check
for outliers that are model based and
generally look for outliers based on
mean and variance of the data outliers
can be excluded from the analysis or
included while using algorithms that
treat outliers as well
there are other outlier treatments but
are out of scope for this chapter
let us quickly summarize what we have
learned in this lesson we have discussed
what analytics and Analysis are and the
differences between them
popular tools used in analytics what a
data scientist does the processes
involved in the analytics life cycle how
to formally Define a problem statement
methods of collecting and summarizing
data for Analytics
data dictionary and its contents what
outliers are and how to detect and treat
them
the section will help you to check your
understanding of the concepts covered
the last two decades have witnessed
extensive business infrastructure
Investments due to this the capability
of collecting data has improved across
Enterprises while some businesses
continue to operate in their traditional
ways in other businesses each aspect is
now virtually open to collect data these
aspects are even instrumented for data
collection aspects like Supply Chain
management marketing campaign
performance manufacturing operations and
workflow procedures are a few examples
simultaneously information is also
available on events like industry news
market trends and movements of
competitors
the wide availability of data has led to
increasing interest in methods to
extract useful information from data
science
with this data availability
organizations in almost each industry
are focused to exploit data for their
advantage over competitors
earlier organizations used to employ
different teams of analysts modelers and
statisticians for manually exploring
data sets however now the variety and
volume of data have outstripped the
manual analysis capacity computers have
also become powerful and networking has
become widespread also algorithms are
being developed that can help connecting
various databases to allow powerful data
analysis as a result of all these
phenomena various data science
principles and data mining techniques
are coming into existence
a manager in an organization needs to
take several decisions on the basis of
the problem and alternative courses of
action available to conclude the best
option they need all the information
that is relevant and the Criterion to
choose the best option here's a set of
questions that can be important for any
business executive
some other interesting questions that
could be important to business
executives are also listed on the screen
let's first understand what business
analytics is it's a scientific process
that transforms data into Insight it
takes data from various sources and
various types and convert them into
insights that improve support and
automate decisions
the techniques used for this process are
presentation technological and
quantitative in other words it's a
process that uses data for better
decision making it's used for fact-based
or data-driven decision making this is
generally considered as more objective
as compared to other decision-making
alternatives
business analytics uses simple tools
such as reports and graphs and also
complex tools such as optimization Data
Mining and simulation in the graph shown
on the screen we've compared different
data analytics techniques in terms of
competitive advantage and degree of
complexity prescriptive analytics offers
the most competitive advantage over
other techniques such as descriptive and
predictive however performing
prescriptive analytics is the most
complex data analytical technique we'll
look into details of each of these
techniques in the subsequent screens
let's now talk about the features of
business analytics or ba the first
important feature is the support to
various methodologies these include
Concepts from applied probability
Applied Mathematics applied statistics
and computer science since it's used by
organizations that are committed to
data-driven decision making the data
produced helps in gaining meaningful
insights into better business planning
and business performance
the next important feature is decision
support systems in data-driven companies
data is treated as a corporate asset
successful analytics is dependent upon
the quality of data and analysts who
know the business and Technologies
Solutions are primarily used as decision
support systems or as their components
the solutions help Executives
salespeople and other organizational
leaders to make business decisions
another important feature of business
analytics is business continuity support
as business analytics supports essential
business functions and also supports
tactical decision making with respect to
unforeseen events it also AIDS in
functions such as hiring reducing
attrition improving retention performing
staff deployment and deciding strategy
in many cases decision making is
automated for supporting responses in
real time
this lesson will help you understand the
concepts related to different types of
business analytics such as descriptive
analytics Predictive Analytics
prescriptive analytics supply chain
analytics Healthcare analytics marketing
analytics human resource analytics and
web Analytics
descriptive analytics analyzes the past
events and predicts the approach of
future it analyzes the past performance
by mining the past data and look for the
reasons why past failures or successes
happen almost all management reporting
such as Finance operations marketing and
sales uses this Analytics the related
models quantify data relationships in a
manner that is generally used for the
classification of customers and
Prospects into various groups for
instance these models can be used to
classify customers on the basis of their
preferences and life stages they can be
used to create further models that can
make predictions and can stimulate
various individualized agents some of
the data techniques used by this
analytics includes reports data mining
techniques descriptive statistics data
queries data dashboards and basic
what-if spreadsheet models
Predictive Analytics converts data into
actionable and usable information it
determines the possible future outcome
of an event or the possibility of a
situation it includes various
statistical techniques from machine
learning data mining modeling and Game
Theory and include techniques that use
models created from past data to predict
the future or determine the impact of
one variable on another
when it comes to businesses these models
use the patterns found in transactional
and historical data for identifying
opportunities and risks they allow risk
assessment by capturing relationships
between various factors the three basic
cornerstones of this analytics are
predictive modeling and decision
analysis and optimization and
transaction profiling an example to use
this analytics can be to optimize
customer relationship Management Systems
some other examples include a company
that can create a mathematical model for
predicting the future sales by using
past data on product sales and a food
manufacturing company that can estimate
the measurement and quality of unit
sales by using the point of sale scanner
data from retail outlets
a few other examples include an
organization that can predict the market
share of a new product by using the
survey data and past purchase Behavior
using Predictive Analytics these
organizations can analyze the spending
use and behavior of customers this leads
to effective cross sales and high
profitability an organization must
employ an experts team or data
scientists to find and access the
appropriate data this team can work with
Business Leaders for Designing business
strategies by using Predictive Analytics
techniques such as time series analysis
linear regression data mining techniques
and simulation or risk analysis
prescriptive analytics uses mathematical
Sciences machine learning business rules
and big data for making decisions and
suggesting decision options it specifies
the best course of action for a business
activity in the form of the output of a
prescriptive model it goes beyond
predicting the outcomes of future and
also suggests the action to benefit from
the predictions it anticipates the
reason of an incident and not just what
and when it will happen it can also
suggest decision options on the method
to take the benefit of a future
opportunity or to mitigate a risk of the
future the models used in this analytics
are called optimization models and
combine various business rules
mathematical models and data the input
can be internal data external data and
various other sources
here are some example Industries in
which this analytics is used
the airline industry can benefit by
using Revenue management models and past
purchasing data as inputs to get the
best pricing strategy across all flights
similarly the finance industry can use
portfolio models that utilize historical
investment return data to decide the mix
of Investments
other examples of prescriptive analytics
are supply network design models in
operations and price markdown models in
retailing in operations supply network
design models provide cost minimizing
plant and distribution center locations
retailing use price markdown models that
provide the timing of discount offers
and revenue maximizing discount levels
one of the traditional analytics
applications was in Supply Chain
management and Logistics it's used at
the core of companies like FedEx and UPS
it's used for efficient delivery and
optimal sorting of goods it's also used
for vehicle and staff scheduling vehicle
routing better inventory and processing
control and efficient Supply chains
analytic tools used in this area span
the complete analytics Spectrum for
instance it's been used by the women's
apparel manufacturer Bernard Clause Inc
the company used a descriptive analytics
for presenting its supply chain status
to its managers another example is
ConAgra Foods a packaged Foods company
which used prescriptive and Predictive
Analytics for planning its capacity
utilization better by including the
inherent uncertainty in Commodities
pricing the company received 100 return
on their investment in analytics in less
than three months
analytics and Healthcare is used to
simultaneously control cost and provide
more effective treatment to patients
predictive prescriptive and descriptive
analytics are used to improve staff
patient and facility scheduling they're
also used to control inventory
purchasing and patient flow for instance
as per the McKinsey Global Institute or
MGI and McKinsey and Company 14 study by
better utilizing analytics the United
States Health Care system could save
more than 300 billion each year which is
equivalent to the complete gross
domestic product of countries such as
Singapore Finland and Ireland
marketing is one of the expanding areas
to apply analytics a better
understanding of customer Behavior by
using data generated from social media
and scanner data leads to several
advantages such as better use of
advertising budgets effective pricing
strategies improved demand forecasting
better product line management and
increased customer satisfaction and
loyalty one of the example is automobile
manufacturer Chrysler tuned with JD
Power and associates they developed
predictive models for supporting their
pricing decisions for automobiles says
they helped Chrysler to better
understand the ramifications of proposed
pricing structures the models generated
an estimated annual Savings of 500
million dollars
the use of analytics in the Human
Resources area is relatively new with
the use of analytics the HR function
ensures that the organization employs
the required skill sets to meet its
needs hires the highest quality Talent
provides an employee retention
environment and achieves its
organizational diversity objectives
Sears Holding Corporation or shc is an
example in this area it created an HR
analytics team inside its corporate HR
function that used descriptive and
Predictive Analytics to support employee
hiring and tracking and influencing
retention
web analytics is the analysis of online
activity such as visiting websites and
social media sites like LinkedIn and
Facebook it has huge implications for
promoting and selling products and
services through the internet
some points to remember are that leading
companies use descriptive and advanced
analytics to data collected in online
experiments for determining the best way
for configuring websites position ads
and using social networks to promote
products and services
online experimentation includes exposing
various subgroups to various website
versions and tracking the results these
experiments prove to be ineffective as
they allow the company to use the trial
and error method in statistically
determining what makes a difference in
their website traffic and sales
why is decision making in any business
very important the goal of business
decision making is to high Revenue low
costs and low expenses it's supported by
business analytics in various ways such
as for increasing Revenue while keeping
selling expenses the same
business analytics suggests changes in
the Salesforce deployment it can also be
used if a company's employees are
leaving voluntarily for higher paying
jobs and there are high onboarding costs
in such cases business analytics
recommends raises that can help retain
existing employees
business intelligence or bi refers to
reporting and analytics tools
traditionally used for determining
historical data Trends these techniques
and tools are used to transform raw data
into useful information for the purpose
of business analysis it includes a set
of processes methodologies Technologies
and architectures that uses the output
of the information management processes
the Technologies can handle large
amounts of unstructured data for
identifying and developing and otherwise
creating new strategic business
opportunities bi enables queries by
which users can get results by asking
data related questions it allows easy
data interpretation of high amounts of
data while implementing an effective
strategy based on insights that can help
a business gain a competitive advantage
bi includes tools that are designed to
present the results of analytics in an
understandable format they provide
historical current and predictive views
of business operations
some functions include online analytical
processing process mining prescriptive
analytics text mining business
Performance Management and benchmarking
data science includes processes
principles and methods to understand
phenomena through automated data
analysis it allows data-driven decision
making or DDD which determines the
productivity of an organization DDD is
the practice of basing decisions on data
analysis instead of just intuition
organizations get involved in DDD to
lesser or greater degrees which decides
the productivity of the organizations
the given image shows how data science
interacts with the outer world
let's now talk about the importance of
data science you can consider data
science a business asset that is about
data investment an understanding of its
fundamental concepts is required for
data scientists and anyone working with
data scientists employing data
scientists investing in data heavy
Ventures or directing an analytics
application in an organization DDD and
Big Data Technologies improve business
performance substantially data science
supports DDD and at times performs such
decision making automatically
with respect to data science the key
strategic assets are data and the
ability to extract useful information
from data many businesses use data
analytics to get value from the existing
data and to generally consider if the
business has the right analytical Talent
incorrect data and unsuitable data
science Talent results in issues such as
poor decisions
Big Data typically refers to data sets
that are too large for traditional data
processing systems ITS Technologies are
considered as a popular platform for
data analytics and data exploration and
used to implement data mining techniques
and data processing
these Technologies are also used to
process data in support of the data
mining techniques and other data science
activities nowadays companies that
employ Big Data technologies have
started asking what can I now do that I
couldn't do before or do better than I
could do before
therefore it's possible the Golden Era
of data science
different types of analytical tools
available are listed on the screen these
are open source software have object
oriented design and can be linked with
General programming platforms they also
offer extensibility and various other
features business analyst interview
questions
my name is Richard kirschner with the
simply learned team get certified get
ahead
we'll go over some beginner intermediate
and advanced level questions to expect
in interviews when you're looking at
business Analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question dealing with business because
in business they want to make money and
we really want to understand where the
split is on a lot of these things so
always ask yourself where is the bottom
dollar on this and what does this mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening so
risk is a potential problem that can be
predicted risk me or may not happen in
the future a proactive response plan is
formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there is no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on
this is very
company specific and so when you start
looking for work you start going in for
interviews you should start really
asking yourself what are these companies
looking for that I'm interested in
clearly if you work with IBM you want to
have your tools that are Central to IBM
and the IBM setup same thing with Google
with you know just across the whole
field some of the more basic ones
obviously an Excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list but your python your
SQL you should really know your SQL is
going to come up and no matter what
format you're in your Tableau your Azure
your balsamic all these are different
platforms there's a lot more out there
but you should be aware on which
platforms your proficiencies are on and
those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer questions and a lot of
companies will pay for you to be
certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand any one of these in a little
bit more detail than just knowing the
list what is feasibility study a
feasibility study is a method of gauging
the success rate of proposed Business
Solution it enables business analysts to
discover new business opportunities
and really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at it for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility that is a
very central question that comes up in
most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done what is business model
analysis business model analysis is a
technique that helps you analyze if a
business is financially economically and
socially viable or not
I know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in Colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that so it's a very high-end job
Niche we really need to know your stuff
and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs we look at requirements
requirement is a targeted solution that
is required to achieve the set business
objectives business requirements are
data used for business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result business needs include
identifying and comprehending the
businesses goals and articulating its
strategic direction and you can think of
needs are what do we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip PIN codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using Excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes PIN codes of various cities from
the US and India here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography click on the
insert data option choosing City from
the field list click on the insert data
option and select state from the field
list
really you do need to know your way
around Excel no matter what other
packages you're working with Excel is
such a base package in business analysis
so much people are given that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
Baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in India
you can use the sum IF function to find
the total revenue generated from India
you can see here equals some f and then
of course B2 to B100 India L2 to l1001
and that will give you the sum you can
also use a filter option to filter the
data only for India and use subtotal by
pressing alt plus equals nice short
hotkey to remember there
create a highlight table to visualize a
revenue generated from offline and
online sales for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies used to have blue
but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use you
drag the region onto columns drag the
cells Channel and item type Fields onto
rows select the total revenue column and
drag it on to color and label cards
select Square as the mark type
drag the total revenue field onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows Place item type column onto
colors under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select Asia
so one of the things about tab blue is
it looks real complicated but it's all
drag and drop and so you should know
your way around about doing some very
simple drag and drops for doing your
query in summation and below is the
resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
uh differentiate between software
development lifecycle and Project Life
Cycle
if you're looking a little bit more
hierarchical towards the top of the list
software development life cycle helps
with the development of software
products it consists of a single
software across multiple phases here
phases include requirement Gathering
coding operations maintenance and
documentation
where the Project Life Cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business Project Life Cycle consists
of multiple software and one customer
scenario phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
Analysis how do you perform risk
management in your project so again
we're dealing with intermediate not just
how to pull tables across we're going to
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced assessed
and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high
risk avoidance whereas risk avoidance is
carried out to avoid the risk from
occurring meanwhile the business impact
here is zero and the cost is fully
eliminated and you can think about a
brick and mortar store and they have
shoplifting you want to mitigate as you
want to avoid as much shoplifting as you
can but you can only Frisk people at the
door and have security so much before
you start losing customers and so when
you mitigate it you're going to have to
pay for your lost merchandise where you
avoid it you have your security cameras
and people watching to stop people from
stealing things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent badly spent on equipment
certifications there's all kinds of
areas where you want to mitigate and
avoid risk
what are project deliverables project
deliverables represent a collection of
measurable services and goods that are
to be delivered to the end user in the
project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model two of our biggest or
most basic models used today the agile
model which is slowly taken over
especially in software the agile model
is adaptable to requirement changes and
has an incremental approach
in the agile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology changes
and requirements are difficult to
implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
Final Phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be ready to change
quickly when the waterfall setup you're
not looking for fast changes you're
looking for a very solid it's going to
work no matter what kind of view this is
something that we can build it doesn't
have to make major changes but it better
work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like Moscow and SWAT
Moscow analysis it is a prioritization
technique that highlights a
requirement's significance question like
is it a must-have or a should have could
the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here
in the SWOT analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
SWOT analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats and
you cannot kind of think of it as like
the SWAT team coming in
to you know you're worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in Moscow really what is
um what can we get out of this you know
is this do we have to have it to succeed
is it going to be useful in the future
so you're looking more for a general
value attached to it list various
components of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives Mission strategies action
plan what is benchmarking
benchmarking is a process of evaluating
an organization's measures like the
quality of policies programs Etc against
the standard criteria
it's so important to have that Baseline
of what are you measuring against the
Baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure it
against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before I even jump into this I have a
friend who is working with some very
high-end individuals who took their
private plane
and he was supposed to meet him at the
end location when he arrived they had
been in a fist fight while on their
private plane the stakeholders had so
much difficulty with some particular
aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
that work with anybody but you want to
listen patiently to the stakeholders
point of view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically
have a one-on-one discussion to make
things more precise comprehend their
worries and be transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and I'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the ignore somebody who's being
difficult but the rest of it is stay
focused stay focused on what you're
trying to accomplish be goal driven this
is a great time to be goal driven not
driven by emotion or the problems that
arise or how the person communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum you'll get scrum certified
important thing to look into if you
haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming XP
feature driven development FDD
Crystal kanban Dynamic systems
development method dsdm if getting your
learning started it's half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
out and having a kind of a general idea
that the other ones are out there is
important to at least know what we're
talking about when someone comes up and
talks about agile
describe the Gap analysis Gap analysis
refers to the analysis of differences
between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the Gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result Gap
analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities and
you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import to text file data into
Ms Excel and remember Excel is one of
those things that has been around
forever and even though it's like the
bottom barrel of a lot of analysis that
we do most of our data starts in an
Excel spreadsheet
or comma separated variable file that
you then end up with an Excel
spreadsheet given below is the employee
text file it has information about name
agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into Excel go to the data tab click on
get data drop down under from file
select text CSV select where the text
file is located in your system and click
on import click on low data imported
into Excel
he had been given sales data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of Statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this what
we do is go ahead and select a cell in
the table go to insert and click on
pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table drag region and item type onto
rows drag total profit onto values sort
the sum of the total profit column
sales table find the percentage
contribution of Cosmetics to the total
revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values right click
on the revenue value under show value as
select percentage of grand total right
click on a profit value under show value
as choose percentage of grand total and
you can see here when we do that we end
up with Cosmetics made a 14.03
contributions to the total revenue and
an 18.94 contribution to the total
profit how do you create a dual axis
chart in Tableau drag the order data
onto columns and convert it into
continuous year drag total revenue onto
rows and total profit to the right
corner of the view until you see the
light green rectangle
synchronize the right axes by
right-clicking on the profit axes under
the marks card change sum total revenue
to bar and sum total profit to line and
adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data Create A View to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has the least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an Excel file
data in Tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column under rows place the total
profit column under calor and choose the
desired color palette sort the unit sold
axes in descending order
and you can see here it produces a very
quick bug figure shows the fruit sold
and the least and had the least amount
of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
Middle East and North Africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select Middle East and North
Africa
Bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time Iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017. drag
the unit sold filled on the columns drag
the region and item type Fields onto
rows under the cooler card place a total
revenue column drag item type onto
filters and choose close meat and baby
food drag the ordered date column onto
filters and select 2016 and 2017. meet
had the highest units sold it made the
maximum profit now with any of these
Tableau it's good if you have your own
hands on for this
so that's an important thing to note we
kind of zoomed in on Tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with Tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package that's a good thing so at least
you know what we're talking about and
you've had that Hands-On
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization we had Moscow
Technique we mentioned that earlier the
requirements are grouped based on must
mandatory should high priority could not
necessary but preferred and would
suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
um
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no notional one
hundred dollars to distribute among the
requirements so the 100 method is pretty
similar to what the ranking method is
top 10 requirements and this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
pick their top 10 requirements
this is very popular there's a lot of
help books out there about getting
things done they say write everything
that you want to accomplish put them on
three by five cards and narrow it down
to five do those five because once
you've conquered those five then you can
move on to the next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
Sprint burn down
so the Sprint burn down is the chart we
use when you're tracking usually it's in
scrums where that usually comes from the
scrum setup but it's a chart of the work
to be completed and what's still going
on
you have your work category allocation
the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness time coverage defect
resolution time explain bpmn
bpmn business process model and notation
Gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique Which models the
end-to-end business process step the
four essential elements of bpmn are flow
objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations swim Lanes pool or Lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about Gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews
I don't know how many times I've been on
the phone calling competition
potential clients to ask questions
so one of the elicitation techniques is
to ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions and a lot of
terms also turn into additional sales
document analysis Focus Group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important I just kind of
highlight a few of them that I tend to
get stuck in observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis and you're bringing
people into a workshop and do
observations in the workshop and working
specifically with these people they turn
into potential business growth I tell
you what if you're a shareholder and
someone's doing a business analysis and
they turn around and generate a thirty
thousand dollar sale for your company
they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay and you're doing what you like which
is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
Survey questionnaire survey is my least
favorite but they are the most popular
because they're the easiest to pump out
listed documents needed by a business
analyst
initiation document project Vision
document use cases system requirements
specifications document
business requirement document
requirements traceability Matrix
functional requirement document use case
specifications document gap analyst
document describe how you would approach
a project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams tracking
the project documenting the progress
and really when you start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here is so important with the
shareholders if you I mean it's great if
you can identify your project goal
that's probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal you
might as well walk away
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements collaborating
with other teams that is such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case different steps
are used to complete the goals of a use
cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors this
does not lead to achieving the required
goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting analytical reporting is a type
of business reporting which provides
data analysis information and
recommendations it enables people to use
data to make decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following point should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis display
your analysis skills think critically
and I'm going to throw in here the term
from Big Data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph a very simple set of
notes and you need to think critically
you need to really make it what is it
that the shareholders want that's going
to make them understand why this is
important to the business and what does
the business get out of it what is
kanban
and helps agile teams in visually
managing work through processes it works
as a scheduling system in agile just in
time production the kanban methodology
is all about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of work
the kanban board describes a current
development status
and of course when you're working with
kanban you've got to be very careful
about
[Music]
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a
micromanagement setup where you want to
you want to watch out for that but you
also need to track everything
a basic kanban board has three-step
workflow as the to do in progress and
done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
ity differences between BRD and SRS
BRD business requirements documents is a
high level functional specification of
software
BRD is a formal document to describe the
requirement provided by the client
business analysts create this post their
interaction with the clients
SRS system requirement specification is
a high level functional and Technical
specification of software SRS describes
the software's functions and
non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas SRS is
created by the systems architects
what is Pareto analysis the Pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most relevant
and the least decision concerning the
overall goal
is also known as the 80 20 rule as per
this rule 82 percent of the projects
benefit arises from 20 percent of the
work vice versa eighty percent of the
case problem can be due to 20 percent of
the causes
differentiate between the V model and
the fish model
we talk about the V model it is an sdlc
model where the execution of processes
happens sequentially in a V shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step
V model consumes less time and cost the
fish model is similar to The V model but
with more multiple verification teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness the
fish model is compared to the very
costly and time consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage from
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each Region's country that made the
highest revenue
create a pivot table by dragging the
region and Country onto rows place the
total revenue column under values right
click on the country value select the
filter options and choose top ten choose
top 1 as shown above and click on OK
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the sales data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than three
thousand you need to use an advanced
filter option in Microsoft Excel to
solve this problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select Advanced filter option choose
copy to another location give your
criteria range and the copy to location
we'll click on OK
here's a final result as we can see
below let's create a pivot table to find
which countries from each region made
the lowest amount profit create a pivot
table by dragging the region and the
country into rows Place The Profit
column under values right click on any
country value select the filter option
and choose top 10 choose bottom one and
click on OK
let's create a field map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America using Tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text drag
total profit under color and the filters
card drag the region column and select
North America in the filters card drag
the item type column and select
beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see that Greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in North America
who knew
using Tableau how will you display the
top five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit select both the
sets right click to create a combined
set give a name to the set and choose
all members in both sets drag the new
set on the filters and the total profit
onto color
the above graph depicts the Cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest and really when we're
talking about tools like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r or you're targeting companies
working in Python you should be able to
quickly do these kind of displays in any
of those packages that you're focused on
Tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also very robust and
easy to use and uses less programming on
the back end so just a quick side note
on there roll your sleeves up if you if
this does not look right to you you're
not able to get through some of these
things make sure you are if that's what
you're targeting in a company for an
interview if you stand on this session
on the business project analyst full
course should you need any assistance
PPT project code and the other resources
used in this session please let us know
in the comment section below and a team
of experts will be happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you and keep learning stay tuned for
more from Simply learn staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign